So stimme ich schon, okay.
So, ich mach mal was trinken hier.
Ich bin ja schon am Start.
Wenn wir schon mal da sind, dann würde ich sagen,
machen wir mal Package-Updates.
Arch Linux, by the way.
Alter, wie viel...
Ich hab da ganz schön viel im RAM gehabt,
so wie es aussieht, oder?
Warte mal, cancel. Was hab ich denn da im RAM gehabt?
Kann nicht so viel gewesen sein.
Aber wisst ihr was?
Bei der Gelegenheit
können wir einfach den Stand wegschmeißen,
neu starten, weil ich will eh nur Updates machen
und dann rebooten.
Chat nur für verifizierte Konten.
Oh nein!
Ist aber auch geil, dass man das wieder nicht ausblenden kann, ne?
War übrigens noch nicht
die ganze Zeit so, ne?
Das ist erst seit ein paar Monaten so.
Oder seit ein paar Wochen sogar nur.
Vorher konnte ich mit meinem
Fake-Account, den ich
angelegt habe, dass ich mich hier einloggen kann
auf dem Streaming-PC,
konnte ich ohne
Probleme im Chat schreiben. Das geht jetzt nicht mehr.
Das geht jetzt nur vom
zweiten Bildschirm aus.
Das funktioniert
vom zweiten Bildschirm. Aber hier kann ich nicht mehr.
Kackel. Bam. Geht nicht.
Pack WTF.
Ich muss mal in keinem Browser starten.
Package Updates.
Pac-Man.
Okay, da gibt's nix Neues.
Check for Updates.
Bin immer wieder erstaunt,
wie viel CPU-Last so kleines Zeug
produziert teilweise.
Bäm. So ein Burst.
Einfach 8 CPU-Kerne voll. Oder wie viel
CPU-Kerne hab ich hier? 8, ja.
Ich hab einfach mal
random in dieser VM
mehr RAM und CPU
als manche für ihr gesamte
Heiminfrastruktur
haben.
Ja.
Chatgear, hat jemand
von euch mal, wobei das jetzt
mal gleich, wenn ein bisschen mehr Leute da sind, ist die Chance,
naja, wie auch keine,
auch Package Updates.
Das hätte ich jetzt aber mehr erwartet hier.
Arch, by the way.
Was ist denn da los?
Warum gibt's nicht, warum gibt's nicht mehr Package Updates?
Das ist dein PC, das ist mein Desktop-PC
hier. Oh, guck hier, siehste. Kann ich hier
hin und her switchen.
Zwischen dem ersten Desktop und dem zweiten Desktop.
Und in dem zweiten Desktop
im zweiten Desktop ist einfach Fullscreen
vor allem bei Workstation. Ja, und das ist auch das,
was ich jetzt gerade sagen wollte.
Wenn mehr Leute da sind.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher,
ob das weiterhin die Zukunft hier
von meinem Setup ist.
Mit Windows hier und
Linux in der VM da.
Also das Setup an sich ist
das Beste.
Das will ich auch weiterhin so behalten, aber
ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher.
Ne, wir machen jetzt kein Web-Entwicklungsstelle.
Sieht so viel zu.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr so sicher, ob ich hier
das mit Vmware Workstation machen will an der
Stelle, weil Vmware Workstation
und generell Virtualisierung,
wird immer Desktop-Virtualisierung wohlgemerkt.
Servermäßig juckt es keinen ohne grafische Ausgabe.
Desktop-Virtualisierung wird gefühlt immer
painstchampiger unter Linux, beziehungsweise nicht
unter Linux, ist ja falsch, mit Linux unter Windows.
Ja, erstens hast du diese ganzen Geschichten mit Windows 11
Virtualisierung, die dann Probleme machen mit Vmware
und allem möglichen parallel.
Ja, aber deswegen habe ich auch kein WSL drauf, wobei,
wahrscheinlich hätte ich auch so kein WSL drauf, weil WSL
brauchst du nicht, wenn du ordentlich Linux-VM hast.
Ist einfach immer noch besser.
Anpille, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Und
ja, es gibt, es gab ja die letzten,
letzter Zeit immer wieder, immer wieder Probleme mit
Linux in Vmware, ja.
Wayland funktioniert bis heute nicht richtig
und es wird immer, es wird immer painstchampiger.
Dazu kommt, dass sich gefühlt an Vmware Workstation auch nichts mehr tut.
Vmware Workstation selber ist ja, glaube ich, mittlerweile sogar
kostenlos, was nichts heißen muss.
Es gibt genug super kostenloses Software, aber es hat sich auch
schon davor, wo das offiziell zumindest noch irgendwie 160
Euro oder so gekostet hat, auch nicht mehr viel getan.
Du kannst ja das, du kannst ja das Changelog irgendwie an einer Hand
ablesen, so was sich die letzten fünf Jahre in Vmware Workstation
getan hat, so gut wie nix.
Die haben, die haben ja auch mehrere Versionen und Subversionen gebraucht,
bis die.
E-Cores, diese Efficiency Cores bei den neuesten CPU Generationen
ordentlich unterstützt haben, haben die mehrere Releases gebraucht,
bis das richtig funktioniert.
Und ich bin mir teilweise bis heute nicht sicher, ob der Kram nicht doch
ab und zu mal nur auf E-Cores läuft.
Ja, man kann das alles in der Config dann irgendwie forcen, wie es sein soll.
Aber es ist trotzdem eklig, ja, so.
Und es wird immer, und gerade das Wayland wahrscheinlich irgendwie gefühlt
nie richtig in Vmware funktionieren wird, wobei böse Zungen würden ja behaupten,
Wayland wird alles.
Ja, wenn man sich die richtig funktionieren, jetzt ist es schwierig.
Zumindest habe ich mir überlegt, habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich nicht mal
das hier ausprobieren sollte als quasi Ersatz für Vmware Workstation.
Habt ihr das schon mal gesehen bzw.
habt ihr das schon mal ausprobiert?
Ich gehe mal davon aus, die meisten nicht.
Eventuell hat es der eine oder andere schon mal ausprobiert.
Das ist eine Server Implementierung von Nvidia Game Stream.
Okay, Moonlight.
Aber Moonlight ist die ist das nachgebaute Nvidia Game Stream.
Nvidia Game Streaming gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Das war ja für Low Latency quasi in in-house Streaming.
Ja, also sprich, da konntet ihr zum Beispiel euren Steam Client
auf das Shield TV forwarden und dann dort irgendwelche Games spielen.
Habe ich sogar gezeigt.
Ich habe mal ein Video gemacht dazu vor zig,
jahren, warum auch immer der hier nichts findet.
Mein Wohnzimmer Setup.
Hallo Jungs.
Ja, ja, Max ist gut.
So und das hier am Ende, das läuft über Nvidia Game Stream.
So Nvidia Game Stream gibt es mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Jetzt haben die eingestellt.
Ich weiß auch nicht so genau warum.
Und es gibt mittlerweile aber einen Open Source Nachbau.
Das ist Sunshine.
Sunshine ist die Server Komponente.
Und Moonlight ist die Client Komponente.
Das heißt, du brauchst einen Server.
Also in dem Fall würde ich das halt auf irgendeiner Linux Kiste installieren.
Und dann brauche ich anstatt mein Vmware Client muss ich hier Moonlight öffnen.
So habe ich mir das zumindest gedacht.
Ich habe das selbst noch nie ausprobiert.
Da ist natürlich auch die Frage, auf welcher Kiste probiere ich das aus?
Probiere ich das hier auf einem zweiten Streaming PC auf der linken Seite aus?
Oder und da tendiere ich eher zu, kaufe ich mir so einen kleinen Bandbreite.
Habe ich ja genug.
Habe ich ja mehr als genug.
Im Netz so und da kaufe ich wahrscheinlich noch so einen kleinen kompakten Mini PC,
nachdem ich den, den, den ich hatte.
Ja, ich weiß, das haben wir sogar.
Das haben wir sogar geguckt.
Ja, ich habe ja mal ein Video zugemacht.
Im Leben.
Das ist nicht handgeartet, was
zumindest ich habe.
Ich habe ja ein Video zugemacht.
Ich habe ja so eine, so eine Mini PC.
Kiste gekauft vor einer Weile, sowas hier und der wäre optimal dafür geeignet,
damit mal Sunshine und Linux quasi nicht Game Streaming,
sondern halt einfach schlicht ergreifend Desktop Streaming auszuprobieren.
Da ist die Frage
WLAN.
Wer möchte denn um alles in der Welt so was über WLAN machen?
Also ich würde das hier auf gar keinen Fall über WLAN machen.
Deswegen wollte ich das mal ausprobieren.
Und das wäre halt, das wäre also der optimale PC, um
so ein, so also ein hier, also optimaler PC, um das mal auszuprobieren.
Das Problem bei der ganzen Geschichte ist,
ich habe den nicht mehr.
Ich habe mir das, ich habe mir so eine Emulator Kiste gekauft
und ich habe die Kiste meinem Vater überlassen.
Mit Linux Mint drauf auf erst mal unbestimmte Zeit.
Anscheinend scheint er übrigens mit Linux Mint ganz gut klarzukommen.
Ich hatte in letzter Zeit noch keine großartigen Support Anfragen.
Aber der macht ja auch nix.
Der macht Chrome auf und das war's.
Dann startet das Ding, öffnet Chrome, fertig.
Und und dann und dann will ich nicht wissen, was er weitermacht.
Mein Vater ist jetzt, ich glaube, 75 oder 76.
Dass er angeblich eine 26 jährige Freundin hat, habe ich euch erzählt, oder?
Ja, habe ich bestimmt.
Aber das ist nur.
Ja, das ist nur.
Ein Wunschdenken.
Die ist auch nur seine Freundin, in Anführungszeichen,
weil er regelmäßig Kohle überweist.
Aber okay, er soll ja machen, was er will.
Bisschen cringe ist es trotzdem.
Du hast keinen Laden in der ganzen Wohnung.
Ja, das ist natürlich dann problematisch.
Aber das Problem habe ich nicht, weil die Rechner
würden ja dann direkt nebeneinander stehen, also gar am gleichen Switch hier.
So wie jetzt hier.
Mein Vorschau Rechner, der hier quasi auf der linken Seite ist, die neben dem hier.
Also bei mir ist hier die Display Grenze.
Da kommt ein zweiter Monitor, den seht ihr natürlich nicht.
Also mein Vorschau Streaming Rechner, auf dem könnte ich das auch machen, aber
eigentlich nicht.
Ich will so eine extra Kiste haben, nur nur dafür.
Und ja, das würde ich gerne mal ausprobieren.
Aber ich glaube, ich werde das erst mal, nachdem ich also wie gesagt,
das Ding wäre halt die optimale Kiste gewesen, darauf auszuprobieren.
Aber.
Das habe ich nicht mehr, das Ding.
Deswegen werde ich es wahrscheinlich schlicht und ergreifbar
am Raspberry Pi 4 ausprobieren.
Der Raspberry Pi ist mit Sicherheit kein gutes
Exempel so dafür, wie performant das Ganze sein kann.
Aber einfach mal zum kurz ausprobieren, ob das so prinzipiell funktioniert
und man das auch gescheit bedienen kann, beispielsweise
wenn keine Maus angeschlossen ist und so was.
Weil ich will ja nicht irgendwie eine zweite.
Ich will ja nicht eine zweite Maus benutzen.
Ich will ja meine Maus auf dem Host Rechner benutzen, so wie hier in VMware.
Und das werde ich das wahrscheinlich mal mit dem Raspberry Pi ausprobieren.
Und wenn der Raspberry Pi schon erträglich schnell ist,
dann kann ich davon ausgehen, dass eine echte Kiste mit dedizierter Grafikkarte
oder es ist ja keine wirklich dedizierte Grafikkarte mit so
CPU, GPU, Halb.
Wie nennt man dieses Ding?
Nee, KVM Switch ist auch Sack auch.
Am besten ist, du kannst einfach deinen Host Maus und Host Tastatur verwenden
ohne irgendwelche Umschalt Geschichten.
Ähm, ja, wie heißt das noch mal?
Wenn, wenn CPU und GPU zusammen sind, da gab's noch so ein schönes Wort für
das, das wo, wo AMD damals angefangen hat, wo auch in der PS4 gewesen ist.
APU, genau ja, das meine ich ja.
So ein Ding ist es.
Ist das ja letztendlich, was da drin ist.
Was ist denn?
Wisst ihr, eine Sache, was mich echt verwirrt hat, ist,
als ich mir das hier durchgelesen habe.
Also wir probieren das mal zusammen aus.
Erst mal auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Und wenn das geht, kaufe ich mir so eine Kiste und dann richten wir das da drauf ein.
Dann gucken wir, ob das funktioniert.
Vielleicht ist das echt eine gute Alternative zu VMware.
Hätte zumindest ein paar Vorteile gegenüber VMware.
Erstens müsste man dort nicht.
Also wie sage ich denn das jetzt?
Manchmal würde ich gerne Hardware in die VM weiterleiten, was nicht geht,
weil VMware Workstation kann kein Pass, kann keinerlei Pass through unter Windows.
So und das müsste ich ja dann aber gar nicht machen,
weil ich hätte das Ding direkt auf der Hardware laufen.
Dementsprechend.
Dementsprechend würde dann auch so Zeug funktionieren wie Wayland mit Hyperland und sowas,
was man sich mal angucken könnte.
Was ich ja bis jetzt so rein vom Sehen so massive overrated halte,
aber man weiß ja nicht.
Das gibt es doch für ARM, oder?
Releases.
Gibt es das für ARM?
Mal schauen.
Assets.
ARM64, ja.
Okay.
Das werde ich mal ausprobieren oder das können wir mal im Stream ausprobieren.
Vielleicht ist das echt eine ganz gute Alternative.
Ach ja, und ein weiterer Vorteil wäre.
Aber du kannst auch Proxmox.
Da müsste ich da einen Proxmox draufhauen oder irgendwie einen Host Linux, eine KVM,
die GPU durchreichen und darauf dann Sunshine.
Ganz ehrlich.
Dann verzichte ich auf Snapshots.
Es ist ja nicht so, als kann man nicht sonst auch mal Backups machen.
Ich meine, praktisch ist das.
Ich meine, praktisch ist das natürlich schon.
Ja, da müssen wir gar nicht reden.
Praktisch ist das schon so.
Hey, ich will jetzt was ausprobieren.
Take Snapshot.
Ich habe einen Snapshot vom 30.05.
Ich bin mir unschlüssig, was das für einer ist.
Ich take, ich take mal einen neuen Snapshot.
Und lösche den alten.
Ich habe echt keinen Plan, was das für einer gewesen ist.
Der kann nicht so wichtig sein vom 30.05.
Da habe ich irgendwas hier.
Da sehe ich schon irgendwelches Rust Compile Zeug, sehe ich da im Vorschau.
Ja, da muss ich mal gucken.
Also das probiere ich mal aus.
Vielleicht probieren wir das sogar heute Abend noch aus.
Und wenn das, wenn das halbwegs auf dem Raspberry Pi läuft, dann kaufe ich mir eine Kiste, weil dann muss das auf der anderen.
Wo ich ein bisschen unschlüssig bin, was ich nicht so ganz gecheckt habe, ist, was ist jetzt eigentlich aktuell unter Linux eigentlich die bessere GPU Wahl?
Also du hast ja drei zur Auswahl.
Wenn du nicht spielst, wenn du kein großartiges Gaming betreiben möchtest, dann hast du Intel iGPU.
Wobei das auch so ein bisschen.
Also wenn du da mal ein bisschen Emulator Zeug vielleicht drauf spielen willst von bisschen neueren Konsolen bis bisschen neuere ist sowas wie GameCube oder so.
Dann weiß ich nicht, ob man da mit der mit so einer Intel iGPU so weit kommt.
So die ganze Zeit hieß es AMD.
Aber in letzter Zeit habe ich gehört.
Ist Nvidia wieder irgendwie besser?
Und ich bin.
Ich weiß aber nicht, warum ich weiß aber nicht, warum ich habe das nicht so richtig verfolgt.
Also keine Ahnung.
Auf der anderen Seite ist, glaube ich, die Auswahl gar nicht so, als hätte ich da eine große Auswahl.
Die Auswahl bei Mini PCs ist ja im Endeffekt entweder Intel GPU oder wenn es ein bisschen mehr Wumms haben soll.
AMD Nvidia ist ja da eigentlich gar keine Option bei Mini PCs oder man siehst du nirgendwo.
Es gibt Mini PCs.
Es gibt eigentlich nur AMD mit integrierter AMD APU Grafikkarte.
Mini PC mit Nvidia Grafikkarte gibt es doch eigentlich gar nicht.
Okay, Snapshot.
Das probieren wir bei Gelegenheit mal aus.
Ja, da bin ich.
Da bin ich echt gespannt, ob das taugt.
Weil weil weil ganz ehrlich.
Es ist ja nicht so, als will ich unbedingt vor allem bei Workstation oder als will ich unbedingt virtualisierte virtualisiertes Linux verwenden.
Das ist einfach vom Setup her extrem angenehm.
Dadurch, dass ich es hier direkt auf dem Rechner auf dem zweiten Bildschirm haben könnte, haben kann.
Und wenn ich ein zweites Setup haben könnte, was das gleiche die gleichen Vorteile hat, aber ein Native Linux auf irgendeinem Mini PC ist.
Da wäre ich auch dabei.
Vor allem könnten wir dann beispielsweise GPU Acceleration haben bei Video Decoding.
Also wir könnten Videos decoden, ohne 100% CPU Last zu haben und solche Geschichten.
Das geht ja in der VM nicht.
Auf der anderen Seite würde man jetzt ja sagen, also könnte man ja sagen, das funktioniert unter Linux generell immer nur sehr schlecht.
Mehr schlecht als recht.
Ja, keiner kann irgendwie richtig Wayland.
Nicht mal Wayland selbst.
Ich habe letztens ein Video geguckt.
Da musste ich so hart kecken dabei.
Das gucken wir nicht.
Das ist deutlich zu lang.
Aber wenn mal einer sehen will, der Wahnsinn, der bei Wayland abgeht.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das Video jetzt finde.
Das war auf jeden Fall irgendein Video von.
Weiß ich nicht.
Letzten Monat auf jeden Fall.
Das da.
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Wie gesagt, 34 Minuten.
Da musste ich mich so wegschmeißen bei dem Video, weil das wieder das typische Linux Entwicklungs hin und her ist.
Wobei, das kann man gar nicht sagen.
Bei Linux selbst, da wo Linus das Sagen hat, da gibt es dieses hin und her nicht.
Wenn da irgendeiner was schreibt, was Linus nicht gefällt, dann wird er geflamed und dann hält er die Klappe.
Und dann ist es gut.
Aber in vielen Open Source Projekten geht es richtig ab.
Zumindest, falls mal einer den Wahnsinn der Linux Open Source oder das Linux Open Source Ökosystem sich angucken will, kann ich dieses Video empfehlen.
Das kann man auch im Schnelldurchlauf durchskippen.
Und zwar geht es darum, dass einer einen Pull-Request gestellt hat, einen Merch-Request gestellt hat für Wayland.
Dass man das Window-Icon.
Habe ich überhaupt Window-Icons bei mir?
Ne, ich habe keine Window-Icons, weil ich habe keine Window.
Ohne Window, ja ich weiß, das Video irritiert immer, aber das ist ein altes Video von mir auf YouTube.
Ich habe keine Window, also kein Window-Fenster, also habe ich auch keine Window-Icons.
Window-Icons, so quasi sowas hier.
Und da gab es einen Pull-Request bei Wayland.
Dass, wenn du eine Anwendung hast, die checkt.
Wenn du eine Anwendung hast, die Child-Windows erstellt.
Also, sagen wir mal, dieses Fenster hier, ja, spawnt ein weiteres Fenster.
Dann hat das neue Fenster immer das Icon vom Parent-Fenster.
Obwohl es sinnvoll sein könnte, beispielsweise bei einem Settings-Dialog, ja.
Stellt euch mal vor, ich würde jetzt hier einen Settings-Dialog aufmachen.
Sagen wir mal hier, ich gehe jetzt da hin und sage, ähm, Share.
Wo geht denn der hin?
Ah ja, sehr nice.
Muss ich mal kurz ausschalten, ich weiß nicht, was ich da geshared habe.
Keck Waiting.
Okay, nix.
Es funktioniert überhaupt nicht mehr.
Da habe ich irgendwas, irgendwas attached mal, was es nicht mehr gibt.
Ich glaube, das ist, ich glaube, das ist sogar meine VM.
Ja, also wenn man jetzt hier zum Beispiel das anklickt.
Und ich zeige es euch jetzt mal unter Windows.
Ah, Alter.
Wie geht man auf, ich klicke nicht mehr durch Windows-Windows-Stells.
Also, Chico, Chico.
Von Chico gucken wir uns an.
So, und ihr seht, dieses Fenster hat jetzt ein Child-Fenster gespawnt.
Und das Child-Fenster hat ein anderes Icon als das Parent-Fenster.
So.
Und das geht unter Wayland so ohne weiteres.
Nicht, zumindest nicht, dass man das Icon programmatisch setzen kann.
Aha, okay, alles klar, das war irgendeine VM.
Also, die Anwendung muss quasi ausgeliefert werden mit einem Icon.
Und ich kann nicht zur Laufzeit das Icon setzen.
So, und da gab es ein Problem.
Und zwar, dass unter anderem der App-Image, der App-Image-Entwickler, der hat gesagt,
das ist natürlich doof, wenn du eine Anwendung verpackt hast in ein App-Image, dann wird
die Anwendung immer mit dem App-Image-Icon gestartet und nicht mit der eigenen, mit dem
eigenen Icon.
Und bei Sub-Fenstern für irgendwelche Settings-Windows kannst du das Icon auch nicht ändern.
So.
Und da kann man jetzt eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass es eine ziemlich No-Brain-Angelegenheit
ist, das einzubauen in Wayland.
Zumal es auch nicht super kompliziert ist.
X kann das übrigens auch schon.
Also X kann das ja irgendwie gefühlt seit 100 Jahren schon.
Zumindest, er geht den Pull-Request durch.
Sebastian Wick übertreibt es dann auch wieder richtig.
Er geht den Pull-Request durch ohne Scheiß.
Dieser Pull-Request hat, ich weiß nicht, ob er das, ob er das verlinkt hat.
Hat er den Pull-Request verlinkt?
Merch-Request.
Hier.
Da gab es einen Merch-Request.
Und das Ding ist, das wurde vor 6 Monaten aufgebaut, das Ding hat, ey, ohne Scheiß,
das, guck mal, die Seite lädt nicht mal mehr, so viele Comments hat das, ja.
Die sind wieder, die sind wieder komplett ausgerastet hier drinne.
Und natürlich kamen wieder die üblichen Argumente, dieses Feature braucht man nicht.
Dann kamen irgendwelche Gnome-Leute.
Die gesagt haben, ey, wir machen das in Gnome eh anders.
Wir wollen das aber nicht haben.
Und selbst wenn ihr es einbaut, wir benutzen es nicht.
Das sind eh die geilsten immer, die Gnome-Leute.
Ja.
Also man sieht hier ganz gut das, das, das Beispiel, so wie er es haben will und was halt nicht geht.
Das, das ging dann wirklich riesen Diskussionen wieder.
Die haben hier teilweise echt Romane geschrieben drüber.
Es, wie gesagt, es geht um das programmatische Setzen eines Fenster-Icons.
Wir reden jetzt hier nicht, äh, vor allem.
Was auch ein Feature ist, was so wie er es beschrieben hat, einfach nur sinnvoll klingt.
Einfach nur sinnvoll.
Riesendiskussion, Mann.
Und die geilste Antwort, die es zwischendrin gegeben hat, war, ey, unter X geht das doch.
Warum machst du es nicht unter X und machst es, machst es dann mit X Wayland?
So nach dem Motto, wir programmieren was für X und zeigen es dann mit X unter Wayland an.
Ja, dann funktioniert es doch.
Meine Güte, ey.
Krass, Einer.
Riesending.
Also, da läuft, da läuft so einiges schief.
Also, wie gesagt, ich kann das Video echt empfehlen.
Wie gesagt, gucken wir uns nicht, es ist zu langweilig und zu langweilig.
Aber für jemanden, der das interessiert, es ist...
Wow, wow, das wollen wir jetzt gar nicht gucken, ey.
Einer, das auch nicht.
Weiß nicht, wie ich hier in das Fenster gekommen bin.
Es ist wirklich Wahnsinn, was da abgeht.
Die haben sie nicht mehr alle.
Es läuft auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Anscheinend.
Weil...
Weil es gibt es für ARM.
Und ich hätte jetzt vermutet, dass das automatisch bedeutet, dass es das auf dem Raspberry Pi gibt.
Hoffe ich mal.
Wenn nicht, habe ich gelitten.
Wenn...
Dann weiß ich nicht, wo ich es ausprobieren soll.
Weil, wie gesagt, ich habe meine Mini-PC, ich habe meine Mini-PC gerade nicht mehr am Start.
Ich benutze meinen Vater für Linux Mint.
Äh, what?
Wo bin ich denn jetzt rausgekommen?
What the fuck?
Ach, ich habe das gelöscht.
Ich bin ja auch bescheuerter.
Also, ich probiere es mal aus.
Ich...
Es scheint so, als gibt es den Raspberry Pi nur für den Client.
Aber das Ding hat bestimmt einen Software...
Bestimmt einen Software-Render rein.
Äh...
Funktioniert...
Linux Sunshine auf dem Raspberry Pi?
Nee, anscheinend nicht, oder?
Anscheinend funktioniert das nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Ich will mir jetzt doch...
Ich meine...
Könnte ich, weil so ein Ding braucht man immer.
Ich wollte mir jetzt eigentlich nicht auf gut Glück einen neuen Minion machen.
Ich wollte mich nicht auf gut Glück einen neuen Mini-PC bestellen.
Just for fun und gucken.
Und dann feststellen, es ist doch nicht das, was ich haben will.
Aber irgendwo muss das Geld ja hin.
Big...
Big Stonks.
Was machen eigentlich die Stonks?
Wartet mal kurz.
Wo ist denn mein Handy?
Was machen die Stonks?
Sekunde...
Stonks...
Versuchst immer noch Bash zu verstehen.
Ja, so wirklich verstehen.
Komplett.
Hat das wahrscheinlich noch keiner.
Aber gut genug, dass man damit was machen kann.
Ich glaube, es gibt niemand, der hundertprozentig Bash versteht.
Beziehungsweise Shell Scripting.
Da gibt es so viele oldschool obskure Dinger.
Trading is not available.
Ja gut, es ist Wochenende.
Alter!
Die Stonks sind wieder hochgegangen.
Ich habe knapp plus 10.000 Euro in einem Jahr.
Aber das habe ich ja nur...
Das habe ich ja nur, wenn ich es verkaufe.
Logischerweise.
Aktuell ist es rein virtuell.
Ordentlich.
Big Stonks.
Was sind 10k in Prozent?
Gute Frage.
Sieht man hier nicht.
Es steht hier nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
So.
Package Updates habe ich gemacht.
Nice.
Alles klar.
Wir müssen übrigens auch noch die restlichen Stellenanzeigen machen.
Aber nicht heute.
Nächster Stream so.
Oder übernächster Stream so.
Oder so.
Mal gucken.
So.
Was haben wir denn hier auf YouTube?
Ja, Chat.
Vielleicht jetzt, wo ein bisschen mehr Leute da sind.
Jemand von euch irgendwie Erfahrung mit Sunshine unter Linux?
Das ist eine Open Source Nachbau von Nvidia Game Stream.
Hat das jemand von euch schon mal verwendet?
Ich weiß, da gibt es Tisch Videos zu und sonst was.
Und vom Setup her ist es auch nicht so kompliziert.
Mich würde bloß mal interessieren, ob es irgendjemand von euch schon benutzt hat.
Ob das prinzipiell taugt.
Ja.
Und was ich auch nicht so ganz verstanden habe ist, man kann ja Hardware vom Host verwenden.
Hardware vom Client quasi verwenden.
Also ich kann meinen Controller und meine Maus und Tastatur, wenn ich die beispielsweise
hier habe an meinem Rechner, weiterleiten über Sunshine an den Sunshine Server.
Über Moonlight an Sunshine weiterleiten.
Wie gut funktioniert denn das?
Ist der Mauscursor laggy oder ist der genauso hier on point wie in VMware?
Ne, wir machen jetzt keine Stelle.
Aber ich kann das mal mit aufnehmen, wenn du willst.
Da haben wir noch eine Bonus Stellenanzeige dann für den nächsten Stream.
So.
Erst mal kurz schauen.
Ich habe das letzte Mal quasi fast durchgängig geschwätzt.
Das kriege ich heute nicht auf die Reihe.
Ich habe gestern fast, ich habe letzten Sonntag drei Stunden am Stück gelabert.
Das halte ich, das macht mein Hals diesmal nicht mit.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Rapid R1.
Ey, das ist dieses, das ist dieser AI Handheld, der vor einem Jahr oder vor zwei Jahren ultra
ultra krass gehypt war, wo ich persönlich damals diesen Ultra Hype schon nicht so genau
verstanden habe, weil aus einer Demo hat man nichts gesehen.
Oder?
Oder ist das dieses Wifi Hacking Ding?
Nee, nee, nee, das ist dieser.
Es ist ein Fireship Video.
Das heißt, das muss der AI Handheld sein.
Nino, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Fireship macht gefühlt jedes zweite Video AI, AI, AI, AI.
Ach ja, bevor wir Video anfangen, muss ich ja noch die aktuellen GitHub Trends angucken,
ob es da irgendwas Spannendes Trends, irgendwas Spannendes drinne ist.
Flipper ist das Wifi.
Ja, ich bringe die teilweise durch.
Und da gibt es noch eine 3D Drucker Firmware, die heißt auch so ähnlich.
Ist aber ganz was anderes.
Okay, hier haben wir das erste Projekt.
Ich habe absolut keinen blassen Schimmer, was das sein soll.
A Framework for Claude Opus.
To intelligently orchestrate sub-agents.
Clipper meine ich, ja genau.
Obviously, was das ist, oder?
Anhand der Beschreibung weiß man sofort, was gemeint ist.
Ich würde mal drauf tippen, es ist AI.
Also, wenn ich nicht weiß, was es ist, dann AI.
AI, okay.
Was ist AI?
Aber anhand der Projektbeschreibung hätte ich nicht gecheckt.
Das ist wieder so ein Ding.
Das ist im Trend.
Das weiß ich, dass es im Trend ist.
Weil, da gab es gefühlt 20 Videos von allen möglichen YouTube Leuten die letzte Woche.
Ich habe eh das Ding, ich habe eh den Eindruck, irgendeiner buddelt auf GitHub ein Projekt aus.
Hauptsache Blazingly Fast written in Rust.
Macht dann ein Video zu.
Und alle Channels in dieser Richtung machen auch ein Video zu.
Jetzt habe ich mir gemerkt, das ist das Projekt mit der Ente, glaube ich.
Mit der Ente als Maskottchen.
Ja.
Hat nicht so eine Ente drauf.
Doch, genau.
Es ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich verstehe den Charme von CLI File Manager nicht.
Ich habe es bei Ranger schon nicht verstanden.
Und ich verstehe es bei Yasi auch nicht.
Guck mal.
Der kann sich Bilder im Terminal anzeigen lassen.
Ist ja schön und gut.
Ups.
Ist ja schön und gut, dass der sich Bilder im Terminal anzeigen lassen kann.
Aber ich kann mir sogar GIFs im Terminal anzeigen lassen.
Und das ganz ohne Terminal Style File Manager.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, wozu man Terminal File Manager braucht.
Ich verstehe es wirklich nicht.
Ich habe es bei Ranger nicht verstanden.
Ich habe es bei den ganzen Ranger Clones nicht verstanden.
Ich verstehe es bei Yasi immer noch nicht.
Weil alles, was man so machen möchte auf der Command Line, kann man auch ohne File Manager machen.
Man kann eine Datei einfach moven und man kann eine Datei einfach kopieren.
Man kann auch eine Datei einfach löschen.
Und man kann sogar Bilder anzeigen lassen auf dem Terminal.
Also wozu brauche ich genau einen File Manager?
Man muss nicht mal CD eintippen zum Wechseln.
Ja gut, ob das jetzt so ein krasser Vorteil ist, kann man sich jetzt sicherlich darüber streiten.
Also ich verstehe es nicht.
Also wie gesagt, mir leuchtet es null ein.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe das damals bei Ranger auch schon nicht verstanden, was das einem bringt.
Aber natürlich wundert es mich nicht.
Es ist Blazingly Fast written in Rust.
Natürlich muss das trenden.
Was ist Ghost TTY Github?
Github.
Terminal Emulator written in Sig.
Muss sein, ja.
Keine Sprache ist zu abgedreht dafür, um da drin irgendwelche Sachen zu rewriten.
Wo ist der?
Leute, wo ist das?
Wo ist das?
Der Source Code dafür?
Okay, das ist nicht Open Source.
Okay, alles klar.
Dann fällt es bei mir eh schon mal raus.
Aber ich finde es schon mal nice.
Dass derjenige.
Dass derjenige die ganzen drunter liegenden Terminal Sachen unterstützt für Image.
Für Image Anzeige.
Ja.
Aber wie gesagt, nachdem ich immer noch nicht verstehe.
Okay, lasst uns mal die Vorteile angucken.
Full Asynchrone Support.
All AI Operations are Asynch.
Okay, nice.
Das Ding ist aber halt.
Es ist nicht so.
Also ja, macht sicherlich Sinn.
Das Ding ist halt.
Es ist jetzt nicht so.
In irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Files auflisten in einem Ordner oder sonst.
In irgendeiner Art und Weise jetzt Performance Bottleneck.
Aber es ist Architektur schön.
Ja.
Powerful Asynch Task Manager.
Juckt mich null.
Als Anwender von dem Ding.
Es ist nice to have.
Ja.
Bild in Support von Multiple Image Protokolls.
Habe ich auch so.
Code Highlighting.
Okay.
Das ist in der Tat was, wo ich sagen würde.
Ja.
Ist ganz nice.
Das Ding ist halt.
Es gibt 30.000 verschiedene Highlighter für Textfiles im Terminal.
Ja.
Ich glaube.
Wer auf Rust steht, kann Bad verwenden.
Das kann, glaube ich, auch Dateien highlighten.
Alternativ ist immer noch das Ding.
Wenn ich einfach eine Textdatei öffnen möchte.
Wenn ich eine Textdatei Syntax Highlighted haben möchte.
Dann kann ich die einfach in Wim öffnen.
Ich habe die auch Syntax Highlighted.
Nein.
Ich bin woblos.
Ja.
Es ist.
Es ist schwer.
Ich gebe zu.
Es ist schwer zu verbergen mit meinem Avatar hier auf Twitch.
Ja.
Zumindest liegt.
Also.
Das verstehe ich.
Das verstehe ich auch nicht genau.
Ich kenne das.
Viele Leute finden das nice.
Aber man kann es.
Man hat das auch so schon im Terminal.
Also warum?
Ja.
Okay.
Plugin Systems.
Immer nice.
Was auch immer das für mich als User bringen soll.
Package Manager.
Ja.
Multitab.
Also wie gesagt.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Was man.
Was für ein Vorteil hat mit so einem Terminal File Manager.
Keine Ahnung.
Und ich habe es jetzt beim Durchlesen auch nicht wirklich verstanden.
Was einem das bringt.
Ja.
Denglich auch hier am Start.
Also keine Ahnung was das ist.
Aber wir wollen uns die GitHub Trends angucken.
Äh.
AI.
Sonst.
Äh.
Bestimmt auch.
Ja.
Noch AI.
Vermutlich.
Ja.
Snipe it.
Das habe ich mal bei mir daheim verwendet.
Um..
Da gibt es keine..
Keine Bilder.
Ah.
Um..
Ein bisschen meine Hardware-Sachen zu organisieren.
Ja.
Also zum Beispiel die ganzen Microc oldestune.
Irgendwelche Elektronik Bauteile und so.
Das waren mir mit der Zeit aber auch zu anstrengend.
Ich schmeiße das jetzt nach wie vor alles in ein paar Schubladen rein.
Und wühl dann, bis ich es gefunden habe.
Was ich suche.
Ich weiß so ungefähr wo was liegt.
Das reicht.
Und ich habe, glaube ich, in den letzten Monaten gesehen, dass das Confluence oder irgendein Atlassian-Produkt hat, glaube ich, jetzt auch so eine Inventarisierungsfunktion und die sieht sehr ähnlich aus zu Snipebit.
So als hätten die das quasi, als hätten die das quasi, äh, Homebox, Homebox habe ich jetzt, Homebox habe ich jetzt.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie dieses, wie dieses Tool heißt.
Ne, ah, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest das, was ich gesehen habe, das sah halt sehr ähnlich zu Snipebit aus.
Was? Confluence Data Center? Die haben auch unendlich viele Sachen, oder?
Das, das hört, das hört einfach, Moment, ne, Confluence Data Center ist nur den Kram zum selbst installieren.
Keine Ahnung, zumindest das, was ich gesehen habe, sah einfach, sah einfach Snipebit-Kopie aus.
Ja, Data Center ist doch, ist doch quasi Server, oder?
Ist Data Center nichts zum selbst hosten?
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Data Center und Server?
Ja, genau.
Schade, dass sie das nicht mehr haben.
Früher hatten die Ninjira für, ich glaube, das war sogar kostenlos bis zu drei Entwicklern oder zehn, ne, zehn Dollar hat das gekostet, äh, zehn Dollar hat das gekostet für, für bis zu drei Entwickler.
Und das war eigentlich sehr nice.
Gibt's, gibt's aber nicht mehr.
Schaut ihr mal.
Heute, okay, Jira Pricing.
Ja, da gehen die Stonks steil für Atlassian.
Ja, bis zu zehn kostenlosen User, aber das ist halt Cloud, ne, das selbst hosten ist nicht mehr.
Also, ich verstehe voll und ganz, warum die Hersteller das machen.
Für mich als Anwender ist es natürlich scheiße.
Enterprise, Data Center.
Wo, wo ist die, wo, Preise für Data Center?
Ach ja, ein, ein Schnapper, würde ich sagen.
Hahaha.
Was kostet das denn für, für fünf, fünf, fünfzigtausend User?
Ach nur, ach nur.
Ach, das kostet nur eine Million im Jahr.
Ja, das ist natürlich easy.
Okay, fünfzigtausend Benutzer.
Es ist ja nicht so, als bräuchte es fünfzigtausend Benutzer.
Aber fünf, fünf, fünf, äh, was?
Das ist halt echt teuer.
Aber 30 Tage kostenlos.
Okay, das heißt, du bezahlst das sogar nur für elf Monate.
Ja, das ist schon echt teuer.
Also, ich verstehe, warum das jeder Hersteller machen möchte.
Ja, also, ich meine, eines der größten Vorteile von so einem Service-Modell ist halt, dass dir die Leute nicht von heute auf morgens, äh, von heute auf morgen wegrennen.
Du kannst dich halt drauf verlassen und du bindest die Leute an dich.
Das ist letztendlich ja das, was die haben wollen.
Und das ist für die Hersteller ist das alles eine ganz nice Geschichte.
Für uns als Anwender ist das ziemlich kacke.
Das ist auch gar nicht so lang her.
Da konnte man sich für, glaube ich, zehn Dollar eine Lizenz von, eine Jira-Lizenz kaufen.
Zum Selbsthausten für, ich glaube, bis zu drei Jahre.
Gibt es eigentlich Docker?
Gibt es den Jira-Container noch?
Nee, gell?
Äh.
Und was installiere ich mir da jetzt?
Was installiere ich mir da jetzt, wenn ich das Docker-Image pulle?
Die Data Center Edition?
Okay.
Ja.
Das ist ja schön und gut.
Aber für irgendwie einen 1-3-Mann, ich will lokal ein bisschen rumbasteln.
Da will ich doch nicht mal was, was auf Kubernetes läuft.
Da will ich irgendwie...
Irgendeinen Container starten und gut ist.
Oder meinetwegen einfach auch einen Ordner irgendwo hin kopieren und irgendeinen Binary ausführen und es läuft.
Ja, um das andere nochmal zu sagen.
Das verwende ich heute, um so ein bisschen mein...
Was?
Das wurde...
Das wurde archivet?
Wirklich?
Warum?
Das verwende ich immer noch, um ein bisschen meine Elektronik-Sachen und so zu organisieren.
Hat er keinen Bock mehr?
Hör auf.
Seit wann ist das eingestellt?
Bookstack?
Nee, Bookstack mag ich nicht.
Weil ich mag...
Also, das Ding ist, warum ich Bookstack nicht mag, weil die API früher gesagt hat, das ist mittlerweile vielleicht besser, keine Ahnung.
Und weil es nicht Plaintext ist.
Dementsprechend mag ich Confluence auch nicht.
Aber warum ist das eingestellt?
Aha.
Okay.
Continuing Homebox.
Ach, es gibt schon einen Fork, der ganz gut beliebt ist.
Okay.
Nice.
Ja, das hätte mich jetzt auch wirklich sehr gewundert.
Das hätte mich auch sehr gewundert.
Weil das ist wirklich ein ganz cooles Tool.
Alter, das hier...
Das ist wirklich ein ganz cooles Tool, wenn man seine...
Glaub mich mal ein.
Ja?
Ja, okay, mein Dark Reader macht das gerade ein bisschen kaputt.
Alter, der hat ja das hässlichste Theme als Default genommen, Mann.
Bei mir sieht das nicht so kacke aus.
Okay, dieses komische neue Logo da oben.
Ich habe nur ein bisschen ältere Versionen.
Ja, also das ist wirklich ein ganz, ganz nices Tool.
Halloween.
Excellent.
Das ist wirklich ein ganz nices...
Alter, das sieht ja jetzt kacke aus.
Ich glaube, ich habe bei mir das einfach...
Das Default...
Das Default Dark Theme?
Irgendwie sowas?
Ist ja auch wurscht.
Zumindest, wer seine Hardware organisieren will bei sich daheim.
Ja, wer viele Elektronik-Kleinteile hat, ist das wirklich ganz praktisch.
Diese Übersicht hier, die sieht viel komplizierter aus, als es sein muss.
Im Prinzip gibt es...
Gibt es nur dieses Menü.
Ihr könnt eintragen, wo das Ganze ist.
Und dann könnt ihr hier eure...
Eure Hardware suchen drinnen.
Ja, könnt zum Beispiel...
Was habe ich in meinem Basement?
Okay, Disk 2.
Und ihr könnt danach auch suchen hier.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Disk.
Bam.
Das war es im Endeffekt.
Das war, glaube ich, eine PHP-Anwendung oder sowas.
Super simpel.
Oder eine Django-Anwendung, weiß nicht.
Super simpel, aber echt praktisch.
Wenn man viel Elektronik-Kleinkram hat.
Das sieht nach Daisy-UI aus.
Wollen wir mal gucken.
Was das ist.
Es ist Nuxt.
Es ist Vue.js.
Also ist es...
Weiß nicht, ob man das irgendwie rausbekommt, was es ist.
Sieht man, können wir mal gucken.
Ob wir das irgendwie anhand der Elemente...
Äh, Tailwind.
Es ist auf jeden Fall Tailwind.
Und dann dementsprechend könnte es durchaus Daisy oder so sein.
Weil Daisy ist ja so ein Aufsatz auf Tailwind.
Aber aktuell sieht es für mich so fast schon nach Raw-Tailwind aus.
Stimmt.
Ja.
Das vergesse ich immer.
Hast just recht, ja.
Wobei, das wird hier nicht funktionieren, weil das eine Seite ist, auf der man sich einloggen muss.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob das Funst...
Aber da gibt...
Da gab es...
Nee, wie hieß denn das andere?
Es gab doch auch was ohne...
Äh, Stack oder sowas.
Es gab doch auch...
Es gab doch auch sowas ohne, dass ich ein Add-on installieren muss.
Irgendwie...
Irgendwie What's My Stack oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Geht auch ohne.
Ja, das wird nicht...
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Äh.
Was jetzt?
Ja, das wird nicht...
Das wird nicht richtig funktionieren.
Weil das...
Eventuell blocken die das und beim Login...
Keine Ahnung.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall irgendeine Tailwind-Anwendung.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, es ist Open Source.
Wir müssen eigentlich gar nicht raten, was es ist.
Wir können auch theoretisch einfach nachgucken, was es ist.
Es ist im Backend...
Go.
Okay, wusste ich nicht.
Go und das Frontend ist...
Tail...
Auf jeden Fall schon mal Tailwind-Stells am Start.
Und Daisy UI.
Chatge...
High IQ hat wieder Recht gehabt.
Big Brain Time.
Was der Vorteil ist gegenüber einer Excel-Tabelle.
Pfff.
Wenn du Excel-Tabelle magst, kannst du Excel-Tabelle verwenden.
Das ist sicherlich Geschmackssache.
Also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das...
Irgendwas großartig kann, was eine Excel-Tabelle...
Excel-Tabelle nicht kann.
Das ist halt eine Web-Anwendung.
Die Frage, was du bevorzugst.
Wenn du Excel-Tabellen oder Google...
Google Spreadsheets lieber hast, dann das.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob die Suche nicht vielleicht ein bisschen mehr kann.
Aber ansonsten, wenn du mit einem Spreadsheet fein bist, ist das auch okay.
Also was trenne denn sonst noch?
Webcheck.
Ente.
AI.
Okay.
Okay, das war diese Woche doch tatsächlich ein bisschen interessant.
Nicht nur AI-Zeug.
Moin.
Ja, also wie gesagt, wenn du...
Ich sehe jetzt da kein Killer-Argument oder Feature, was das hätte versus eine Excel-Tabelle oder umgedreht.
Daniel Lohle, dankeschön.
Fünf Monate Subscription.
Excellent.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, dann gucken wir doch mal auf YouTube rein.
Wie gesagt, ich kann heute...
Ich bin schon wieder eine Stunde am Schwätzen.
Ich merke es schon wieder im Hals.
Ich kann heute nicht...
Drei Stunden am Stück durchlabern.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Genau, ich wollte mir das Video von Fireship angucken.
Hey.
Another Controversy for the Rabbit R1.
Apparently this time, its developers wrote some bad code.
Another day...
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Another Controversy...
Irgendwelche Startup-Leute, die irgendein gehyptes Produkt haben, was aber eigentlich Schrott ist,
programmieren auch Schrott.
Controversy for the Rabbit R1.
Apparently this time, its developers wrote some bad code.
Like inexcusably, catastrophically bad code.
A code that allows someone to view every message.
A message ever sent on all devices.
A code that allows the attacker to alter the messages sent to the end user.
And a code that can brick every R1 in existence.
It's outrageous, egregious and preposterous.
Lascivious, salacious, outrageous.
But the most shocking part about this story is what the company did to fix it.
In today's video, we'll find out how this is even possible.
Okay, ich wette, ich weiß, wie die das gefixt haben.
Gar nicht.
Das ist einfach meine Vermutung.
Der Fix ist, wir fixen das gar nicht.
Gerade bei solchen Sachen.
Bei solchen Hype-Startup-Dingern.
Im Prinzip, die denken sich dann ab irgendeinem gewissen Punkt,
wo die Sache nicht mehr zu retten ist,
denken die sich, ey, wir werden damit nie Millionäre werden.
Also, scheiß drauf, wir verpissen uns einfach und machen nix.
Das Ding ist doch kompletter Scam.
Ganz ehrlich, das habe ich bei der Präsentation damals schon gedacht.
Nicht, dass es wirklich Scam im Sinne von Comedy-Gruppe ist.
Aber in Richtung, wir versprechen wieder Dinger, die das halt nicht kann.
Ich weiß noch, bei uns auf der Arbeit war auch einer super gehypt auf dieses Ding.
Wollte sich, glaube ich, auch einen vorbestellen und sowas.
Das hatte ja so seine 5 Minuten of Fame gehabt, dieses Teil.
Aber seit es raus ist, interessiert es eigentlich auch keinen mehr.
Beziehungsweise, seit man weiß, dass es halt auch alles nur Blödsinn ist.
Also, du machst nicht den selben Fehler, wenn du dein eigenes halb gebacktes AI-Produkt schippst.
Es ist Juni 27, 2024 und du schaust den Code-Report.
Ich habe zum ersten Mal den Rabbit R1 bei CES im Januar getroffen,
wo ich von seiner unnötigen Nutzung entstanden bin,
zusammen mit der Anzahl von cringe-Buzzwords, die von ihrem CEO verwendet wurden.
Selbst wenn ich meine Bullshit-Detektoren aufsetze,
haben diese Geräte in den ersten wenigen Minuten Pre-Ordern verkauft.
Aber nach dem initialen Hype,
hat der Rabbit R1 das Lullkall von Tech-Produkten von 2024.
Es wurde als nichts mehr als eine Android-App unter dem Hügel ausgeschlossen.
Es wurde erklärt, dass es...
Wer hätte das nur denken können?
... in NFT-Scams, und wenn es tatsächlich schippt,
war es noch mehr nützlich, als man es sich vorgestellt hat.
Wer hätte sich das nur denken können?
Alles, was irgendwie so in diese...
Ultra-Hype-Richtung geht,
wo Dinger gezeigt werden,
wo aber nie darauf eingegangen wird,
was es eigentlich genau macht,
und was die Absichten damit...
Da muss ich immer dran denken,
okay, es hat sicherlich seinen Grund,
dass sie das alles nicht so genau erzählen wollen,
und der Grund ist in der Regel,
dass es nicht das macht, was sie suggerieren,
und sie die Leute scammen wollen.
Aber mich wundert eh nichts mehr.
Wisst ihr,
was bei mir wirklich der Punkt war,
wo ich gesagt habe,
mich wundert echt nicht mehr,
die Leute wollen sich scammen lassen,
und der Punkt, wo ich am Anfang erstmal die Welt nicht mehr verstanden habe,
war der hier.
Da gab es wirklich Leute,
die haben sich die BitConnect-Präsentation angeguckt,
und haben sich gedacht,
Leute, das ist es.
Alle meine Ersparnisse,
alles Geld, was ich habe,
ich verkaufe alles,
und investiere es in BitConnect.
Das haben sich ernsthaft Leute gedacht,
nach dieser Präsentation.
Und das konnte ich,
ich kann es auch bis heute nicht verstehen,
dass es Leute wirklich gibt,
die das für seriös hielten,
dass man da seine ganze Kohle reinstecken sollte.
Ich weiß, es ist...
Ich meine,
allein schon der Anfang, Mann.
Hey, hey, hey.
Spätestens jetzt.
Natürlich, ihr kriegt alles meines,
alle meine Ersparnisse,
alles, um alle,
meine komplette, komplette...
Weil ihr so super,
nicht nach Scam und seriös ausseht.
Hast du, hast du das Follow-Up-Video gesehen?
Ja, ja, habe ich.
BitConnect.
Bitte dir nicht auch,
dass das extrem seriös wirkt.
Ihr wollt denen unbedingt
euer Ersparnis,
euer Status überweisen.
Also, ich habe noch nie was Seriöseres gesehen.
Da ist ja,
das war ohne Mist, ja.
Wenn ich mir das angucke,
da wirkt ja,
die 25.000 KLS-Verschnitte,
die es da so gibt,
mit Comedy-Gruppe seriöser.
Als das.
Also, keine Ahnung,
was da immer los ist.
Und das war der Punkt,
wo ich es nicht mehr gecheckt habe
und wo ich auch echt kein Mitleid mehr
mit den Leuten haben konnte,
die da ihre Kohle reingesteckt haben.
Keine Ahnung,
da wird bestimmt sicherlich viel,
wenn der Tag lang ist.
Das konnte ich einfach nicht nachvollziehen.
Das hat schon Scam geschrien
nach der ersten Mikrosekunde,
als der Stream lief.
Egal, weiter.
But never in my wildest imagination
would I expect their developers
to make a mistake like this.
Hardcoding API keys directly into the codebase.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Ja.
Ich habe gehört,
es gibt auch deutsche Unternehmen,
die sowas machen.
Zum Beispiel Modern Solution habe ich gehört.
Da stehen beispielsweise auch
Datenbank-Access-Sachen im Source-Code drin.
Habe ich irgendwo aufgeschnappt in letzter Zeit.
Nicht Amthor, Modern Solution.
Da habe ich sogar ein Video zu gemacht.
Da standen auch Datenbank-Connection-Strings
im Source-Code drin.
Und die Datenbank war über das Internet erreichbar.
Das schlägt in die gleiche Kerbe wie das hier.
Was machen die eigentlich so?
Wo wir gerade schon dabei sind.
Aha.
Wo der Entwickler verklagt wurde.
Genau.
Okay, die gibt es noch.
All in one Hosting.
Ja.
Da muss man sicherlich hin.
Moment, was?
Okay, Leute.
Was ist,
was ist
JTL-Wavi-Hosting?
Windows?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe legit keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß auch nicht,
was RDP-Cloud-Hosting sein soll.
Warenwirtschaft.
Ah ja.
Was haben die für Jobs im Angebot?
Wollen wir mal gucken?
Seht ihr irgendwas?
Ich finde diese Webseite ultra unübersichtlich.
Seht ihr irgendwie was?
Karriere oder sowas?
Nee.
Nee, oder?
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Ja, zumindest.
Runterscrollen vielleicht.
Ja, zumindest, zumindest habe ich gehört, dass die auch Connection-Strings im Source-Code
drin stehen hatten.
This mistake was discovered by a group called Rabitude, which is dedicated to reverse engineering
the R1.
According to their statement, back on May 16th, they obtained access to the Rabbit-Codebase.
And inside that codebase, they found hard-coded API-Keys for Eleven Labs, Azure, Yelp and
Google Maps.
The most problematic one is Eleven Labs, which is an AI text-to-speech platform.
When you talk to the Rabbit-R1, it turns your speech into text.
It then passes that text off to a large language model to generate a response.
But before that response goes back to the engine…
Also, man sieht mal wieder, dass dieses Gerät überhaupt nichts Besonderes macht.
Das macht im Endeffekt speech-to-text, pastet es, keine Ahnung, zu Chat-GPT und dann macht
es text-to-speech.
Also, eigentlich nichts, wofür man so ein eigenes Gerät braucht.
... user, that text needs to be converted back into speech, and that's what Eleven Labs
does.
Development of the Atomic Bomb And that means the R1 needs to make an API call
to Eleven Labs for every response ever sent by the R1.
And that means if someone ever got the Eleven Labs API Key, they'd be able to read every
R1 response in history.
They'd be able to change responses.
Das ist schlecht. Also das ist wirklich schlecht, weil wenn das ein API-Key ist für alle Devices, bedeutet das auch, dass ich eure Sprachnachrichten mir anhören kann, beziehungsweise nicht anhören kann, mir angucken kann.
Also alle Sprachnachrichten aller Rapid R1 User kann ich mir angucken. Und da sind mit 99, ganz vielen Neunern vertrauliche Dinger drin, von denen derjenige nicht wollte, dass sie jemand anderes mitbekommt.
So schlimm ist das nicht? Naja, ich finde das schon schlimm.
Du kannst dir quasi alle Responses angucken, alle User, die es jemals gegeben hat.
Also.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das den Leuten so klar war, dass wenn die da was reinreden.
Normal liegt ja auch nur ein API-Key für die komplette Anwendung auf dem Firmenserver.
Ja, ja, aber du hast den API-Key nicht in deiner Hand, dass du den API-Key irgendwo auf der Serverseite gespeichert haben musst, wo du dann von da Requests weitermachst.
Ja, das ist so.
Aber du lieferst den API-Key ja nicht an deine Clients aus.
Du hast irgendeine User-Authentifizierung davor.
Die greifen dann auf deinen Service zu und dein Backend macht den Request gegen 11 Apps.
An den API-Key kommst du ja überhaupt nicht dran.
An den API-Key kommst du nur dran, wenn du deine Cloud-Infrastruktur oder Server-Infrastruktur nicht richtig gesichert hast.
Aber so, die haben ja quasi in der Firmware, in jedem Gerät den API-Key mit ausgeliefert.
Das war ja nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis das jemand ausliest.
Und wenn du das gescheit machst.
Dann liest das auf deinem Server.
Keiner aus.
Nee, das ist normal.
Ja, ach so meinst du.
Ja, das ist normal, dass es nur einen API-Key gibt.
Oder sag mal, normal.
Je nachdem, was die für ein Modell haben.
Aber in der Regel gibt es nicht viele API-Keys.
Solange man da nicht drauf zugreifen kann, ist das vollkommen okay.
Aber wenn man das ausliefert, ist halt doof.
So wie Modern Solution beispielsweise ihren Datenbank-Connection-String mit ausgeliefert hat.
Moin, Michael, 50 Billiarden.
Ja, VIP-Viewer am Start.
48 Monate, POG-Subscriptions.
Hier, danke schön, Leute.
Massive Subs.
Guck grad mal.
Ich hab bestimmt wieder Hälfte gesehen.
Dani Lull.
Ja, doch, dich hab ich gesehen.
Doch, den Rest hab ich.
Anpö hab ich auch schon.
Brogge.
Was?
Hi, Schwarmintelligenz.
Vielleicht habt ihr eine Idee zu meinem Logistik-Problem.
Ich bau...
Alter!
Chat, what the...
Ich will hochscrollen, das geht nicht.
Ja, okay, jetzt geht's.
Warum auch immer.
Vielleicht habt ihr eine Idee.
Vielleicht habt ihr eine Idee zu meinem Logistik-Problem.
Ich bau mein Traum-Office...
Ich bau mein Traum-Office-Zockzimmer und habe drei Monitore.
Mein Hauptmonitor ist ein 34 Zoll.
Links und rechts sagen wir 23 Zoll.
Ich möchte auf...
Ich hab das auch noch nicht gesehen, dass man links und rechts abkürzt, aber sonst nix.
Ich möchte auf meinem neuen 4 Meter Schreibtisch die Monitore auf einem A montieren.
Ich habe nach einer Stunde keine 3 Halter gefunden.
Und 4 Halter halten kann und also...
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Chatge...
Wenn ihr was wisst, schreibt's ihm im Chat.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keinen Monitorhalter.
Ich hab auf meinem Schreibtisch einfach zwei Monitore nebeneinander stehen und fertig.
Fragt doch mal ChatGPT.
Ja, ChatGPT schickt dir auch sicherlich den Amazon-Link gleich mit.
Was ist eure Meinung dazu, wenn in einem Software-Projekt von, sagen wir, Version 256 auf 256 höhere Anforderungen
an die Passwortsicherheit eingeführt werden?
Und von Version zu Version plötzlich Auth nicht mehr funktioniert, weil das alte Passwort nicht den Anfang...
Natürlich ohne Infos.
Da sind die ziemlich dumm, weil sie dann auf einmal, also wenn das nicht im Vorfeld kommuniziert wird,
auf einmal 30.000 oder das sind Zahlen, kann man sehen, ganz viele Subscriptions verlieren.
Sowas musst du im Vorfeld ankündigen und du musst das vor allem in eine gewisse Übergangsphase machen.
Es sei denn, es ist wirklich irgendwas extrem gravierendes.
Detected worden, so nach dem Motto, ey, alle Passwörter sind angreifbar, deswegen müssen jetzt alle gerne...
Was auch immer, ne?
Aber ansonsten brauchst du eine Übergangsphase und du musst das ankündigen.
Sonst hast du...
Jetzt rennen dir die Leute weg.
InfluxDB, ja.
Wendet eh keiner mehr richtig.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Man sieht und liest wenig in letzter Zeit von...
Wenn man sich auf YouTube die ganzen React-Fire-Ship-Tutorials anguckt,
dann packen die da oft einfach den APK...
...hier in die Frontend-Anwendung.
Ja, das ist bescheuert.
Das sollte man nicht machen.
Vor allem nicht, wenn man das dann irgendwie auf GitHub packt.
Aber...
Also mir fällt jetzt kein Tutorial ein, wo das...
Ich gucke auch keine React-Videos.
Ich bin kein React-Programmer.
Sicher, dass die nicht irgendwelche Full-Stack-Sachen verwenden und das im Backend-Teil der Next.js-Anwendung...
...so drinnen ist und nicht wirklich im Frontend.
Also seine APKs ins Frontend packen kann ja eigentlich nur nach hinten losgehen.
Gerade wenn das eine öffentliche Webseite ist.
Wo du dann die APKs in die Welt rausposaunst.
Oder du ein Source-Code auf GitHub publisht.
Ich bin der Meinung, Software muss so entwickelt sein, dass du jederzeit den Source-Code...
Also ich rede jetzt Security-mäßig.
Nicht, ob da jetzt irgendwie super High-IQ-Sachen drin passieren, die du nicht hochladen willst.
Der Software muss so programmiert sein von Credentials her und Secrets, dass du sie jederzeit public auf GitHub pushen könntest.
Siehst du, wenn du den Link aufmachst, ob es ein Ref-Link ist.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich mir den Monitor-Arm kaufen würde aufgrund einer Chat-GPT-Empfehlung.
Ich glaube, darum ging es ihm nicht.
Ich glaube, ihm ging es mit der Chat-Message darüber, zu zeigen, dass viele Leute das nicht verstehen und nicht wissen, dass es eine blöde Idee ist, das reinzuschreiben.
Ja, dass sie das für Tutorial-Zwecke, ich habe ja auch schon Sachen gezeigt im Stream und danach wieder rückgängig gemacht, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Aber die Leute denken dann, ey, das ist kein Problem, wenn wir den API-Key da reinpasten und dann haben sie einen API-Key im Frontend drin stehen.
Das verstehe ich nicht, die Message.
API-Key speicherst du gar nicht auf dem, oder gar nicht in der Frontend-Anwendung.
Ja, das ist auch das Mindeste, was man sagen sollte in einem Tutorial-Video.
Dass man keine API-Key...
...ins Frontend packen sollte, beziehungsweise auch keine API-Keys einchecken sollte in sein Shit-Repo.
Dafür gibt es Git-Ignore-Files, dafür gibt es Environment-Variablen oder irgendwelche anderen Secret-Manager-Tools, dass man sowas eben nicht einchecken muss.
Aber, wenn das doch mal passiert, dann ist natürlich das Beste, was man machen kann, den API-Key löschen und neu anlegen oder neu generieren lassen.
Ja, das...
Weil...
Einmal gepusht, musst du davon ausgehen, es ist im Internet.
Ja, das macht ja nix.
Du musst die ja auslesen können, dass du deine API-Requests machen kannst.
Na klar, wenn du eine Environment-Variable gesetzt hast, kannst du den Inhalt aus JavaScript auslesen, logisch.
Du brauchst den Inhalt, ja.
Was aber nicht heißt, dass du das vom Frontend aus machen kannst.
Vom Frontend aus kannst du das nicht machen.
Das Frontend hat keinen Zugriff auf irgendwelche Server-Site-Environment-Variablen.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, die Leute machen merkwürdiges Zeug, lesen das auf Server-Seite aus und schicken es quasi in irgendwelchen Settings mit an den Client.
Das ist aber halt auch bescheuert.
Dann ist es ja wieder...
Also der API-Key sollte nie auf dem Client liegen.
Ja, ein Wireman...
Es gibt verschiedene Varianten, wie du das machen kannst, ne?
Also, ich sag mal, die drei einfachsten Varianten sind...
Config-File, was nicht eingecheckt wird in deinem Source-Code-Repo.
Config-File, Environment-Variable...
Und Command-Line-Parameter.
Das sind so die drei, die Klassiker, ja.
Es gibt noch viel mehr Varianten.
Spätestens, wenn du deine Anwendung irgendwie containerisiert laufen lässt, kann das auch irgendein Secret-Management-Tool sein.
Irgendwelche...
Wie nennt man das so?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es dafür ein Wort gibt.
Es gibt im Kubernetes-Umfeld, gibt es so Proxy-Sachen.
Nenn' ich das mal.
Da kannst du zum Beispiel deine Anwendung starten lassen, von einer anderen Anwendung, die das dann injectet, als wieder Environment-Variablen zum Beispiel.
Oder du kannst irgendeinen Sidecar-Container haben, mit einem Proxy, der sich um die Netzwerk-Requests kümmert, sodass die Anwendung selbst das nie machen muss.
Da gibt's verschiedene Varianten, aber die Klassiker sind eindeutig Config-File, Environment-Variablen oder Command-Line-Parameter.
Ja, das ist dann ein scheiß Tutorial.
Wenn das so ist.
So.
Äh, wir haben's immer noch nicht geschafft, das Video fertig zu gucken, Mann, Alter.
...which would be an even more absurd mistake, because you should...
Wo sind wir stehen geflogen?
...which I assume is referring to the backend-Rabbit-Codebase.
The details are sparse, but I don't think they actually put an API-Key in their Android-APK, which would be an even more absurd mistake, because you should never put secret API-Keys in client-side-Code.
Even my five-year-old knows that.
It seems more likely that Rabbit has a leaker, like an employee dumping the code onto a USB, and potentially breaking the law to share it.
Leaking is a risky business.
Julian Assange once leaked warcrimes, for which he was treated like a criminal.
Even Hillary said, can't we just drone that guy?
And he just regained his freedom a few days ago.
Now the thing is, when those warcrimes leaked, the warcriminals didn't stop doing warcrimes.
And what's crazy is that Rabbit took a similar approach.
According to Rabbitude, they've known about this exposed 11Labs API-Key for a month, and their solution was to just ignore it and hope the problem...
Ich hab's euch gesagt!
Ich wusste, dass sie... dass er fix ist, einfach nichts zu machen.
...ich wusste, dass sie... dass er fix ist, einfach nichts zu machen.
... Vegas Goodbye.
Überall.
Jede Menge.
Ja, jede Menge.
Es gibt hunderte Open-AI-API-Keys, auf hunderte reicht wahrscheinlich... tausende Open-AI-API-Keys auf GitHub und im Internet schon.
...und viel mehr.
Und viel mehr.
should rotate API keys every 30 to 90 days,
but a high-profile app like the R1,
where it's known that people are actively trying to reverse-engineer it,
could be even more paranoid and rotate their keys every week or so.
And this process can be automated with zero downtime.
There's really no excuse.
Another reason you don't just hard-code
is that for a key that's sensitive, it should also be encrypted.
Tools like AWS Secrets Manager offer multiple layers of protection,
so even if someone gets access to your server,
they still shouldn't be able to get the API key.
And even if someone does try to get access to it,
those requests are logged,
which would immediately identify the leaker,
so Rabbit Management could then put cyanide in their soy latte.
Now, if you own the Rabbit R1, there is a recommended solution,
and that is to douse it in gasoline,
apply a flame to it,
and chuck it in the cola-super-deep-borehole.
This has been the Code Report.
Thanks for watching, and I will see you next time.
Kein Wunder.
Jemand hat ihn in eine Plastiktüte gepackt
und zum Sterben im Müll abgelegt.
Der Plastiksack war zugeknotet.
Eine Passantin rettet den kleinen Kater
und bringt ihn ins Münchner Tierheim.
Hier bekommt er den Namen Leonidas.
Also ich habe ja selten Aggressionen
gegen irgendwelche andere Leute.
Mich interessiert andere Menschen normalerweise einfach gar nicht.
Bei sowas würde ich eine Ausnahme machen.
... von den Pflegerinnen seit ein paar Tagen aufgepeppelt.
Die Passantin hätte sich nicht mehr mit dem Kater verhalten.
Er hat sich nicht mehr mit dem Kater verhalten.
hätte nicht eine Minute später vorbeikommen dürfen.
Sonst hätte Leonie das nicht überlebt.
Er war schon fix und fertig, als die Dame ihn gefunden hat.
Und ganz nass auch.
Wir können nicht genau sagen, wie lange er schon in der Plastiktüte war.
Aber viel hat nicht mehr gefehlt.
Laut Tierschutzverein häufen sich in München
gerade wieder Fälle von ausgesetzten Tieren.
Da peist der so niedlich.
Wie fertig musst du da sein,
dass du so was in eine Plastiktüte stecken kannst?
Wie in fast jedem Sommer.
Wir würden uns wünschen, dass sich die Leute rechtzeitig Hilfe suchen.
Und nicht erst, wenn sie total überfordert sind,
die Tiere vielleicht sogar verwahrlost sind.
Und wir verurteilen auch niemanden.
Uns ist lieber, die Leute ...
Doch, ich schon.
... fragen nach Hilfe, als die Katzen oder die Tiere insgesamt
einfach sich selbst zu überlassen.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Dem 3 Monate alten Leonie, das ist der Schock noch immer.
Aber wisst ihr, was das Gute ist?
Dadurch, dass es jetzt einen Beitrag
darüber gibt, der hat bestimmt schon ein neues Herrchen gefunden.
Ein Herrchen kann man ja nicht sagen.
Neues Zuhause gefunden.
... anzumerken.
Deshalb soll er sich noch 2 Wochen lang im Münchner Tierheim erholen.
Danach suchen die Pflegerinnen dann ein neues Zuhause.
Die haben bestimmt schon eins.
... für den kleinen Kater, der sich darüber freuen würde,
nach dem schrecklichen Erlebnis in liebevolle Hände zu kommen.
Die haben garantiert schon welche gefunden.
Nach so einem Fernsehbeitrag ist das ...
Ja, gehe ich mal von außen rein.
Sehr, sehr geil.
Jetzt, wo ich das hier gerade sehe,
ich muss noch meinen Mobilfunkvertrag kündigen.
Fällt mir gerade auf.
Den werfe ich auch unsinnig Geld in den Rachen seit ein paar Monaten.
Obwohl ich es gar nicht benutze.
Es gibt schon Kack ...
... Personen.
Okay, also.
Was haben wir denn sonst hier noch?
10 Dinge, die wir über das Internet der 90er vermissen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich irgendwas vermisse über das ...
... äh ...
... aus dem Internet der 90er.
Das war halt richtig, richtig nice Retro damals.
Ohne Retro zu sein.
Aus heutiger Sicht war das Retro, ja.
Damals war das hier voll Bleeding Edge, super modern.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da überhaupt irgendwas draus vermisse.
Eine Sache, die ich damals wirklich cool fand, aber das gibt's heute in der Form eigentlich immer noch.
Plus, heute ist es Reddit ...
... äh, und sowas, waren Newsgroups.
Und es gibt von mir mega cringe Newsgroup-Posts.
Wo ich als kleiner Hüpfer angegeben hab mit irgendwelchen Gaming-Achievements.
So richtig, so, äh, so richtig Kack-Spaß-mäßig, Alter, so, oh Mann, ey, wenn ich das heute lese, schrecklich, so nach dem Motto, oh lol, wie kann man so schlecht sein und nicht 120 Sterne in Mario 64 haben und sowas.
Ich hab das so teilweise ultra cringe.
Ich hab so total cringe-ige Shit gepostet.
Es gibt ja Newsgroups-Archive, die findet man heute noch.
Oh, ne, aber gut.
Ich geh davon aus, dass viele Leute, die damals zu den Call of Duty-Hochzeiten, so 2011 rum, 12 rum, also da, wo ich aktiv war, ne, auf YouTube, am Start waren, das waren da auch zwölfjährige, nervige Kinder.
Und die sich heute auch ...
Alter, was ich damals für Kommentare gepostet hab unter Videos, ist schon ganz schön cringe gewesen.
Okay, lass mal gucken, was ...
Was ist es denn?
... has become so ingrained into our lives in the 21st century, that often today ...
Alter, das ist laut!
... we take it for granted.
And a lot of that initial excitement we felt about being online back in the day seems to have gone.
Now, don't get me wrong ...
Okay.
... it still blows my ...
... downloading WAV and MIDI-File.
Mi ...
Das ist was, was ich auf jeden Fall ...
... auf jeden Fall nicht vermisse aus den ...
... aus dem Internet der 90er-Jahre.
WAV-Files waren einfach nur unsinnig groß.
Und MIDI-Files haben sich einfach nur kacke angehört.
Winamp.
Winamp, Winamp.
It really whips the llamas ass.
Oder irgendwie so.
Wie war das?
... our hard disks.
But even before the days of Napster ...
... and before the widespread adoption of MP3-Files ...
... we ...
Der Real Player, alter!
Das war damals das Ding schlecht.
Das war der VLC der damaligen Zeit, der Real Player.
Gibt's das heute überhaupt noch?
Real Player.
Gibt's das Ding noch?
Anscheinend.
Wir haben's auch schon mal aufgemacht hier.
Jetzt ist es ein One-Click-Video-Downloader mit irgendeinem komischem Zeug.
Das gibt es wirklich noch.
Pläne?
Was?
Das ist ein Abo-Modell mittlerweile?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Das ist ein Video-Downloader mit Abo-Modell.
What the fuck, alter?
What?
Okay.
Außer dem Logo ist da, glaube ich, nix mehr da.
Die haben einen Blog.
Okay.
Von 2020.
Alles klar.
Also, Real Player war das VLC der damaligen Zeit.
Ja.
Real Player konnte die meisten Formate abspielen damals.
Ja, und das war eines der ersten Videoplayer, die Streaming konnten.
Also, dass du quasi eine Datei, während sie runtergeladen ist, schon abspielen konntest.
Was wichtig war, weil die Dateien waren relativ groß und die Verbindung war relativ lahm.
Das heißt, du wolltest eigentlich schon anfangen, das abzuspielen, während es noch runterlädt.
Sonst hättest du jetzt erst mal ewig warten müssen.
Ja.
Also, Real Player war das Ding damals schlechthin.
Und Real Player konnte, glaube ich, mit den Nöten ab.
Und Real Player konnte, glaube ich, mit den nötigen Plugins, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, wie das war, auch die ersten encodeten Filme abspielen.
Damals wurden ja, wenn man sich Filme runtergeladen hat, natürlich nur selbst gerippte, vorher hochgeladene Sicherheitskopien, was sonst.
Die waren ja dann in Xvid und DivX und sowas, falls sich da noch irgendjemand dran erinnern kann.
So ganz merkwürdigen Formaten.
Ja.
Und die hatten dann auch so eine richtige Schrottauflösung und pixelig as fuck.
Aber, ja.
Ja, aber Real Player, Real Player war das Ding.
Wav ist das Problem, dass die Dateien, und die sind sie heute auch noch, die sind halt ziemlich groß.
Es war nicht usable wirklich damals.
Das war zu groß zum Downloaden.
Das war zu groß zum Downloaden und es war auf jeden Fall auch zu groß zum Speichern.
Du konntest, damals hattest du Festplatten, die hatten 120 MB, wenn es hoch kommt.
Da konntest du dann, keine Ahnung, fünf, sechs Wapp-Files drauf speichern, dann war es voll.
...as the data didn't require on the fly decoding.
The downside of uncompressed audio means that the files are actually quite big.
A single 4 megabyte song would weigh in at around 42 megabytes in Wav format.
Yeah.
But then, meant that you needed a lot of floppy disks to split and join them together.
Or a zip drive, if you were downloading them at school to take home.
And 42 MB could even be bigger than your main hard disk on your computer.
So rather than downloading full...
Also ich hatte, ich glaube, mein allererster Computer, der hatte, glaube ich, 120 MB Festplatte.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher.
Oder 720.
Es war auf jeden Fall noch eine ganze Ecke unter einem Gigabyte.
Das dürfte so 1995 oder so gewesen sein.
Nee, ich glaube 120 MB.
Das erste Schrottding.
Nee, das war nicht 95.
Das muss früher gewesen sein.
95 heißt ja, in zwei Jahren kam Half-Life 1 raus.
Das muss wahrscheinlich auch so 93 oder so gewesen sein.
Nee, kenne ich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das ist ein bisschen wie ein Counter-Strike-Clan, was damals jeder gemacht hat.
Wir waren drei Leute, ja?
Drei Leute.
Übrigens, da war auch mein Freund aus der Schule dabei, wo ich euch letztens erzählt habe.
Ihr wisst schon, ne?
Ich will das nicht thematisieren.
Weiter.
Aber ich habe es euch erzählt, ja?
Der war da auch dabei.
Der leider nicht mehr unter uns weilt.
Und da haben wir eine Webseite erstellt für unseren Counter-Strike-Clan damals.
Das dürfte dann so...
...1997 oder so gewesen sein, weil CS war ein Half-Life-Mod.
Half-Life kam 1997 raus.
Und damals haben wir schon minimalstes JavaScript gebastelt für die Webseite.
Das gab es damals schon.
Mit Dreamweaver.
Kennt jemand noch hier Macromedia?
Macromedia Dreamweaver?
Ja, nicht 8, keine Ahnung.
Eine uralte, uralte Version.
Das war richtig geil damals.
Das war ohne Mist, Leute.
Das war schon ziemlich advanced.
Man hatte...
So sah das im Endeffekt aus damals, ja?
Man hatte so einen HTML-Editor und auch einen JavaScript-Editor.
Und der hatte damals schon Code-Completion.
Du hattest hier schon die Möglichkeit, HTML-Text zu completen.
Und JavaScript-Sachen zu completen.
Und der war richtig advanced.
Der konnte sogar schon so Sachen wie Content-Type beispielsweise completen.
Du hast dann geschrieben Content.
Der konnte Attribute completen.
Bist hier reingegangen.
Da hat er dann zur Auswahl gehabt, Text, HTML und sowas.
Das war für die damalige Zeit, war Dreamweaver wirklich super advanced.
Und der beste HTML-Editor oder Web-Development-Editor, was es gegeben hat.
Besser als Frontpage.
Frontpage war ja irgendwie so nur Visual-Kram.
Und hier konnte...
Konntest du zwar auch Visual klicken, aber hast hauptsächlich im Source Code.
War der beste Editor, den es damals gegeben hat.
Und ich habe den lange verwendet.
Ja, auch mit FDP-Sync und solche Geschichten.
Irgendwann ist das dann ein bisschen so weggefallen.
Es gab noch einen anderen Editor.
Der hatte auch Auto-Complete.
Aber da komme ich jetzt nicht mehr drauf, wie der hieß.
Das war so quasi die kostenlose Variante zu Dreamweaver.
Das war eigentlich nur ein Editor mit HTML-Auto-Complete.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, wie das Ding hieß.
Vielleicht weiß es einer von euch.
Old School HTML-Editor.
Gucken wir mal, was es da so gab.
Dreamweaver.
Nee, Dreamweaver gibt es nicht mehr.
Dreamweaver gibt es nicht mehr.
Habe ich Dreamviewer gesagt?
Dreamweaver.
Dreamweaver gibt es nicht mehr.
Es gibt noch die alte Version.
Das hat irgendwann Adobe gekauft.
Die haben ja dieses ganze Makromedia-Zeug zum größten Teil eingestellt.
Du kannst es, glaube ich, noch kaufen.
Aber das macht eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Ja.
Ich weiß.
Hieß das nicht irgendwie Proton HTML oder sowas?
Nee, nicht Proton.
Irgendwie HTML-Editor oder sowas?
Proto-Editor oder?
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Es gab noch so eine.
Nufo-Editor?
Nee.
Keine Ahnung.
Und es gab noch so eine kostenlose Alternative.
Wobei man sagen muss, zur damaligen Zeit,
die ganze Software, die war ja alles nur durch irgendwelche Lizenz-Keys geschützt.
Und da gab es keinen Online-Zwang und sonst was.
Also, es hatte damals jeder gefühlt,
das komplette Adobe-Package, das komplette Makromedia-Package,
ohne einen Cent dafür zu bezahlen.
War es.
Falls sich da noch irgendjemand dran erinnern kann.
So hat man den Krempel.
So hat man das damals Serials und Warets.
Hat man den Kram damals bezeichnet, ja.
Oh Mann.
Ja.
Das war, das war nice.
Zumindest damals gab es auch schon ein bisschen HTML und JavaScript.
Eigentlich, worauf ich raus wollte.
Das war, das gibt, Making Personal Websites.
Vermisse ich das wirklich?
Aus dem Internet der 90er?
Was gab es denn damals?
Ne, Lycos war da als Suchmaschine.
Das waren die mit dem Hund.
Tripod und sowas gab es damals.
Geo-Cities und was sonst noch alles für Web-Hosting-Dinger.
Alter, die Weebs waren damals schon am Start im Internet.
Ja, ja, ja.
In 2020, most of us were all over social media, sharing Nuggets and stories of our daily lives
and spewing out our thoughts and opinions in videos and tweets.
But in the days before Facebook and Twitter, if you wanted to share your mind with the
collective Internet, you would need to set up your own website.
Services like Geo-Cities, AngelFire and FreeServe gave users a few...
FreeServe, ja, ja.
Aber gab es nicht was, was Tripod oder so hieß?
Was?
Die Tripod-Websites?
Gab es das nicht?
Doch, doch, doch.
Ach, das war das von Lyricos.
Ja, genau.
Ja, ja.
Ich erinnere mich.
Dunkel.
A few megabytes of free storage to host your own website, usually in return for them, displaying
some form of banner advertising on your site.
And when Geo-Cities launched in 1994, it really did start a revolution of personal
homepages.
And these could be about any topic you liked.
And it really is hard to...
Ähm...
Alles von dir sharen mit Ausweis, Kopie und sonst was, ja.
Mein Schulkolleg von damals hat dann eine kostenlose DE-Domain dafür beantragt.
Three Pages, ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Genau, sowas in der Richtung war das, ja.
Das war noch Zeiten vor Google.
Damals hat man noch mit Fireball gesercht und sowas.
Gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Fireball Search?
Okay, das gibt es immer noch.
Hat aber heute null damit zu tun und ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur ein Google oder ein Bing Frontend,
um irgendwelche Klicks zu generieren auf irgendwelche, ja, ja.
... und hatte einen Texteditor und natürlich ein paar Anim-Gifte.
... in ihrem Arsenal.
Natürlich.
... und hatte einen Website.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, das ist auch sowas.
... und natürlich ein paar Anim-Gifte in ihrem Arsenal.
Ja, animierte Gifte, das ist auch sowas.
Hättest du mich das gefragt 1995, so nach dem Motto, welche der Technologien von heute sind 2024 noch relevant, so.
Ich wäre im Leben nicht auf animierte Gifte gekommen.
Und animierte Gifte waren auch eine Zeit lang komplett.
Let out.
Niemand hat animierte Gifte mehr verwendet.
Erst so die letzten sieben, acht Jahre wieder ist das immer wieder vermehrt aufgekommen.
Und jetzt ja eigentlich mittlerweile Mainstream animierte Gifte.
Also ich hätte wirklich nie daran gedacht, dass animierte Gifte 2024 noch ein Ding sind.
Dreamweaver, beste, beste.
Don't forget the under-construction graphic.
Of course the Starfield backdrop was mandatory.
The now defunct blink tag probably all over your web.
Die Leute benutzen heute nicht GIFs, weil sie retro sind, sondern weil sie praktisch sind.
Weil GIFs quasi das einzig wirklich cross-Plattform auf egal wie alt, egal wie neu, Hauptsache Browser-Möglichkeit ist, animierte kleine Clips abzuspielen oder Emotes oder so.
Ich meine, mittlerweile hast du, glaube ich, die Möglichkeit noch mit...
Was ist das, WebM oder sowas?
Kannst du ja theoretisch auch Animationen machen?
Ist das WebM?
Nee, WebP.
WebP ist es, glaube ich, gell?
Aber trotzdem, es sind immer GIFs.
Und damit hätte ich echt nicht gerechnet, dass 2024 animierte GIFs noch so ein Ding sind.
Damals.
Ich hatte damals tatsächlich eine relativ...
Relativ populäre...
Webseite.
Und zwar für Diablo 2.
Ich habe damals eine Webseite gemacht für Diablo 2.
Da konnte man sich grob den Wert seiner Items...
Ich nenne es mal errechnen lassen.
Da hatte ich am Ende, glaube ich, über 45.000 Besucher drauf.
Das war enorm viel damals, ja?
Und da konntest du dir dann beispielsweise, wenn du irgendwelche Juwele...
Wenn du Juwele-Drops hast, konntest du dir quasi dann ausrechnen, okay...
Wie viel ist das ungefähr wert?
Habe ich dann aber nicht weiter gepflegt, weil ich halt dann nach ein paar Jahren keinen Bock mehr auf Diablo 2 hatte.
Aber ihr könnt euch vorstellen, das war auch ein Game, da habe ich so extrem viele Stunden reingesteckt.
Leider, nachdem ich GeoCities 1999 gekauft habe,
eine Dekade später, würde Yahoo den Service und alle Webseiten darin verlassen.
Effektiv, verlassen sie eine große Reihe des frühen Internet für immer.
Glücklicherweise, hatten sie die Fortsicht, den ganzen Server zu verlassen.
Als ein Torrent-File.
Und heute bedeutet das, dass man diese alten Webseiten auf Archiv-Services wie Internet Archive,
OO Cities und Neo Cities browsen kann.
Der Rest davon erlaubt dir sogar, deine eigenen HTML 1.0 GeoCities-Style-Retro-Webseiten zu kreieren.
Die haben ein niedliches Logo.
... in 2020.
Und obwohl viele GeoCities-Webseiten heute eher vomittend sind,
und ich sicherlich nicht zu meinen alten GeoCities-Webseiten beinhalten werde,
die leider in dieser Kollektion archiviert wurden.
Da gibt es definitiv etwas, was wirklich lecker und nostalgisch ist,
Ich könnte davon ausgehen, in den Browsern damals hat diese Webseite geruckelt wie Sau.
... diese Webseiten heute.
Nummer 8.
E-Mailing-Memes zu einander.
Nein, das hat man 1990 oder im Internet der 90er nicht gemacht.
Damals kannte niemand das Wort Meme überhaupt.
Natürlich, heute sind Meme ein zentraler Teil der sozialen Medien.
Sehen Sie etwas lustiges auf Facebook oder Instagram und taggen Sie Ihre Freunde,
ist etwas, was Millionen von Malen pro Tag weltweit passiert.
Aber Meme in den 90er-Jahren waren ein bisschen anders.
Damals, wenn Sie eine lustige Grafik oder eine Humor-Liste hatten, die damals sehr populär war,
und Sie das mit Ihren Freunden oder Kontakten teilen wollten,
mussten Sie sie auf eine E-Mail anrufen.
Und das hat meistens dazu geführt, dass Sie eine schnell steigende Liste von vorherigen E-Mail-Memes durchführen mussten.
Vorwürfe, Vorwürfe, Vorwürfe, Vorwürfe, Vorwürfe, Vorwürfe.
Ja, das passiert heute im Business-Enterprise-Umfeld immer noch.
Übrigens, hier steht es mal im Klartext.
Kaum jemand weiß heute, wofür CC und BCC steht.
Hättet Ihr das gewusst, ohne dass es jetzt dahinter steht?
In dem Screenshot?
Ich meine, jeder weiß, dass es quasi eine Kopie ist von der E-Mail und dem Motto.
Aber hättet Ihr wirklich gewusst, wofür was CC steht?
Oder was BCC steht.
Ja, okay, der Chat ist einfach zu massive.
High IQ durch die vielen Subs.
Der Chat ist einfach zu schlau.
Der wusste das alles.
Ehe schon.
Oh, Leute, meine Nackenstütze ist gerade nicht in den Nacken gerutscht.
Ich kann mal wieder hoch machen.
Ich hab da so ein Kissen hinten dran.
Genau.
Chat ist einfach zu schlau wieder gewesen.
Ähm, Carbon Copy, das kommt von, ähm, Durchschlag, genau, Durchschlag.
Leute, da bin sogar ich ein bisschen zu jung für, aber ich kenn das auch noch.
Es gab früher für die Schreibmaschine, gab es beispielsweise, oder man kennt das, ihr kennt das vielleicht noch von Überweisungen früher.
Da gab es sowas.
Da hast du das ausgefüllt und dann hast du so einen Durchschlag.
Ja, und.
Das ist, das ist damit gemeint.
Das ist die englische Variante von diesem, von diesem Durchschlagspapier da, wie auch immer das richtig heißt.
Und zu solchen Zeiten kommt das halt noch.
Ne, Pauspapier ist wieder was anderes.
Pauspapier ist so durchsichtiges Ding gewesen, wo man drauf malen konnte.
Pauspapier ist das Gegenteil von diesen Durchschlagsdingern.
Ja, bei dem Durchschlagsdinger, da schreibst du auf was und dann wird es auf was drunter liegen.
So, bei Pauspapier, das legst du drüber, dass du, dass du...
Du quasi nachmalen kannst.
Pauspapier ist das quasi das Reverse Carbon Copy.
Und du hörst ja.
Dein Freund musste wirklich ein bisschen Arbeit machen.
Wisst ihr, was es damals auch Nerviges gab?
Ketten-E-Mails.
Quasi das elektronische Gegenzug zu irgendwelchen Kettenbriefen.
Und die waren damals schon genauso dumm, wie heute Spam-Messages sind.
So nach dem Motto, leite diese E-Mail an 10 Personen weiter innerhalb von einer Woche.
Wenn du das nicht machst, fällt dir beim nächsten Mal irgendwie Ziegelstein auf den Kopf und du stirbst.
Und solche Dinger.
Richtig, so richtig dumm.
So, so was wie heute Copy, so, so, so, so Ketten-Mail-Copy-Pasta-Spams, die gibt es ja heute immer noch.
To choose the people that they thought would find the E-Mail amusing, then select you from their E-Mail-Adresses in their contacts book and send it on.
Ja, und hier übrigens, Chat-Gil.
Then select you from their E-Mail-Adresses.
Outlook, Outlook Express.
So, change my mind.
Aber immer noch das beste E-Mail-Programm, was Microsoft je mit Windows gebundelt hatte.
Ich meine, in der heutigen Zeit nicht mehr usable, ist klar.
Aber es war gut benutzbar.
Es hatte alle Funktionen, die man gebraucht hat.
Und es war irgendwie logisch aufgebaut.
Leider hat es damals schon auch öfter Sicherheitsprobleme gehabt.
Aber Windows-Mail und das ganze Zeug kannst du teilweise echt knicken.
Das fühlt sich eher an wie eine Tablet-Anwendung heute, als wie eine Desktop-Anwendung.
Outlook Express war der beste gewandelte Mail-Client für die jeweilige Zeit, die sie je hatten, aus meiner Sicht.
Ich verwende seit Jahrzehnten gefühlt Thunderbird, deswegen ist es mir sowieso eh wurscht.
Nummer sieben, Chat-Rooms.
Chat-Rooms?
As exciting as the World Wide Web was in the early days, one of the cool...
Naja, Chat-Rooms, was soll ich sagen?
Gerade die früheren MMOs waren ja zum größten Teil ein Social-Chat-Simulator, im Endeffekt, mit Gameplay dabei.
Chat-Rooms.
Ich glaube, wer zur damaligen Zeit irgendwo im Internet unterwegs war und mal in einem Chat-Raum,
wird sich überlegen können, was man da so gechattet hat.
Und wahrscheinlich war es zur damaligen Zeit auch so, dass wahrscheinlich alle Mädels, die da angeblich in dem Chat waren,
in Wirklichkeit irgendwelche Typen waren, die gesagt haben, sie sind Mädels.
... experiences was joining your first real-time chat-room.
And I still remember...
... the first web-based chat-room I went on.
And it would have been in around 1995.
Back then, we had a few PCs at my school that were connected to the Internet.
And you could book them out in hour-long blocks once per day.
And I remember a kid before me, not closing down his session, Netscape was still open, and he'd left the Pearl Jam Chat-Room open.
Now, I'm not into the band Pearl Jam, I've always been into my soul, house and dance music really, but seeing these people chatting away on the screen in real time to each other,
really...
... captivated me.
And I ended up staying on there and talking to them.
And then...
Und irgendwann, und irgendwann hat man dann festgestellt, man kann auch in sowas wie IRC gehen, anstelle von irgendwelchen komischen Web-Chat-Dingern und sowas.
Aber IRC war schon damals für die richtigen Hackermans, und ist es im Endeffekt auch geblieben.
IRC hat nie den großen Mainstream-Durchbruch gehabt.
And then, I started visiting that website and spending an hour or so each day, chatting to people on there until I got to know them quite well.
Then, unfortunately...
... the school did ban Chat-Rooms, as they thought it was a waste of the academic network's resources.
And there were loads of...
ICQ, ich weiß meine ICQ-Nummer immer noch, aber ICQ wurde abgeschaltet vor ein paar Monaten.
... around the same time as well.
We had the Park, the Globe, and one of my favorites, the Web-Chat-Broadcasting-System, WBS.
And I wasted far too much of my school and college time on these websites.
And of course, AOL and Yahoo Chat were really popular, with Yahoo later allowing voice chat into their channels, which...
... was really...
... was really just made up of people playing really low bitrate and single...
Das erinnert mich immer wieder an ICQ, den AOL-Messenger und den MSN-Messenger und was es da nicht alles gab.
... Britney Spears-Songs to the rest of the channel. It was a bit annoying, really.
But IRC was where the real geeks hung out.
Ja, aber IRC, ohne Scheiß, IRC hat es nie zum Mainstream geschafft.
Software like Merck, you could connect to other like-minded people...
Das war schon immer so ein bisschen Hackerman und es ist auch geblieben.
... client of choice.
... und chat as much as your phone bill could take.
Today, chat rooms have mostly been replaced by services like Discord and WhatsApp and Kik and of course video chat sites, but IRC actually remains somewhat...
Kik? Seriously? Kik?
... with the more technical crowd.
And there are still web and Java-based chat services around, such as a WBS-Replica site that was launched in 2009.
And Omnichat remains online, actually since 1995.
But today, even though the sites are still live...
their virtual ghost towns, with only a few messages a month, compared to their busy 90s heyday.
Number 6. Watching webcams.
One of the web's most popular early websites was the Trojan Room coffee pot.
Set up in 1991 and running on an Akon Archimedes computer at the University of Cambridge, originally it was set up so people working in the building could see if the pot was filled with coffee remotely to save them a disappointing walk down the stairs.
This...
There's one more webcam-story from my training, from 2007.
It was almost modern, yeah.
There was...
Can you still remember those Occupy-demonstrations?
That were a long time ago.
In the end, they were based on people starting to camp in Frankfurt.
After a while, there were hardly any demonstrators left.
All the people from Frankfurt...
basically, they were happy that there were tents and stuff like that there.
All the Occupy-stories.
That was around 2007.
And there was a huge Occupy-demonstration announced in Frankfurt.
Against capitalism and the system, or whatever the system is.
And back then, we had our old camera, our old camera that was at the entrance of the computer center.
It was no longer at the entrance of the computer center.
Back then, we had taken it off,
I mean, it was already gone, it was not even at the entrance of the computer center.
Back then, we had taken it off, right where it was.
And we hung it up outside of the building,
above the window.
I mean, not outside, inside of the window,
where the window was a little to the outside.
And then we connected it,
and connected it to the remote,
and connected it to the computer center,
haben uns quasi einen Live-Feed
von den Demonstrationen von daheim über
X-Forwarding mit SSH angeguckt.
Ultragrasses Geek-Zeug.
So mit einem FPS.
Das war eine Kamera, die hat
kein Video-Feed, die hatte nur
Einzelbilder. So quasi
das war das MJ-Pack, so ein FPS.
Ja, Firefret-Move.
Das war im Prinzip,
damals hatten wir
einen
quasi
fast direkt am Willy-Brandt-Platz,
wo die Demonstration war.
Und fast dort
hatten wir halt auch unser Haus,
Hochhaus vielleicht ein bisschen viel gesagt,
ich glaube das hatte was an das 12-Schock-Werk
gehabt und
da hatten wir
die Kamera positioniert, sodass man sehen konnte.
Das war ein riesen Hit auf der frühen Webseite.
Als die Kamera im Jahr 2001
aufgehört wurde, bekam sie News-Coverage
in den Times, den Washington Post,
The Guardian, Wired und viel mehr.
Und andere Webcams folgten in ihrer Richtung.
Massive Resolution, hä?
...
Moment, das wurde shutdown?
Gibt's das nicht mehr?
Das erste woran ich da denken muss, waren irgendwelche
äh, ja,
zweifelhafte Videos.
...
Ist jetzt was anderes, okay.
Der Vorgänger von Firefox, quasi.
Man sieht schon, das hat
eine gewisse, gewisse Ähnlichkeit.
Wobei, wobei das nicht
an Netscape liegt, sondern
Mosaic, oder Mosaic,
oder wie man das richtig ausspricht,
hatte schon so den grundsätzlichen Aufbau.
counter-message
Ja, aber Netscape war
eine Zeit lang so der Browser.
Bis dann Internet Explorer
leider um die Ecke kam.
Und dank Bundle mit Windows
dem ein bisschen den Rang abgelaufen hat.
...
Das kenne ich nicht.
Das ist Internet-History, die ist neu für mich.
Oh, nee.
Das war quasi Bubakam,
bevor die Mädels realisiert haben,
dass man damit Geld verdienen kann.
Und ich meine alles.
Wie ich schon gesagt habe,
ich denke, das ist die beste Idee,
die ich für das dumme Internet-Ding gehört habe.
Und dann hatten wir Josh Harris,
der seine ganze Leben in einem Internet-TV-Show,
wie dokumentiert in dem Film,
wir leben im Publikum.
Nummer 5. Modems.
Jetzt, nicht mich falsch zu machen,
ich würde meine mehrere hundert Megabyte
immer auf Fiber-Verbindung für alles in diesen Tagen wechseln,
aber es gab etwas Besonderes
über die Geräusche, die in deinem IS-...
Brrrrrr.
...P, back in the day.
...The audio coming out of your modem
as it negotiated a connection with another machine over the...
By the way, ich habe bis heute nicht verstanden,
warum das Modem einen Lautsprecher gebraucht hat
für uns zum Hören.
...Phone line was always met with a sense of impatient excitement,
ready to get on and quickly download your e-mails...
Weil danach ging das ja auch ohne.
...and maybe save a few FTP-Files
or maybe even download a couple of websites,
but it's ready.
By the way, ich konnte euch damals
anhand des Einlog-Geräusches
sagen,
mit wie viel...
äh, nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle...
Kilobit
das Modem gesynkt hat.
So...
Ja, soweit hatte ich diese komischen Sounds schon analysiert.
Also ich wusste anhand der Länge von welchem Sound
und was der wann wie welche Sounds gemacht hat, wusste ich ungefähr
mit wieviel Kilobit der gesynkt hat.
Nur anhand des Sounds und ich wusste schon,
ah, jetzt macht er das wieder, jetzt kommt dieser Sound,
jetzt hat er wieder mit zu wenig gesynkt.
Da musste nochmal ausmachen, nochmal neu einwählen.
...for offline reading as quickly as you could
before you ran your phone bill up to astronomical levels.
2007, okay, das ist natürlich schon heftig noch mit Modem.
Every second that you spent online really did count back then.
And if you are nostalgic for the old sounds of technology,
there is actually a brilliant website that preserves a lot of them called
savethesounds.info.
Number four, choosing your search engine.
Ja, damals gab, das war halt noch pre-Google.
Sure, today we've got a choice of websites like Bing or DuckDuckGo
for the more privacy inclined user, but let's be honest,
the vast majority of people just use Google.
With an 87% share of all websearchers going to Google in 2020,
it's been the majority search engine for the last 15 years.
Und letztendlich halt auch das Ding, was Google nutzt.
Was Google mit den tries hat, was Google Kohle bringt, in Massen,
seit ... Jahrzehnten quasi schon.
... and any attempts to topple it have really been futile.
Does anybody remember cool?
Nö.
But it wasn't always the case.
Yahoo! Keckweh, Alter.
Back in the 90s, we were really spoiled for choice ...
Wusstet ihr, dass Yahoo zweimal die Gelegenheit hatte, Google zu kaufen
und es nicht gemacht haben?
Sie hätten Google einmal kaufen können als Technologie,
weil die zwei Google Gründer waren damals bei Yahooen,
Yahoo und haben denen quasi ihre Suchmaschinen-Technologie angeboten, wollten sie nicht und dann ein paar Jahre später für, keine Ahnung, 60 Millionen Dollar oder so, stand Google nochmal zum Verkauf und Yahoo wollte wieder nicht. Und heute gibt es Yahoo nicht mehr. Ich meine, Yahoo ist wahrscheinlich noch online unter der Seite, aber Yahoo als eigenständiger gibt es nicht mehr.
Da muss ich mal überlegen, damals gab es noch Katalogseiten, die die Webseiten quasi Hand von Hand kategorisiert und geratet haben. Es gab damals Bücher, die konnte man sich kaufen mit den besten Internetseiten drin. Also Linksammlungen, quasi Offline-Linksammlungen.
Findet ihr nicht auch, dass das ein bisschen wie das Jenkins-Logo aussieht? Der Dude? Das sieht aus wie das Jenkins-Logo, oder?
Und es gab AltaVista für die Rest von uns. Nicht zu erwähnen, alle kleineren Webseiten wie Lycos, Hotbots, Excite und viele mehr.
Das Leben könnte heute viel einfacher sein, wenn alle nur Google benutzen, aber es war schön, eine Wahl zu haben.
Nummer 3, Webrings.
Was? Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Das bezieht sich an die Zeiten, in denen wir alle unsere eigenen persönlichen Webseiten hatten. Ein Webring würde euch andere Webseiten von...
Ach, sowas. Okay, vermisse ich das. Nö.
...Friends oder an ähnlichen Themen.
Das ist quasi ein bisschen das, wie Sub für Sub heute.
...Ein Stück HTML am Boden deines Homepages. Es würde dann eine Reihe von Webseiten suggerieren, die der Benutzer besuchen möchte.
Ja, Follow for Follow, genau sowas ist das.
...Bevor die Tage von Facebook-Adverts oder der Promotion eurer Webseite.
Ja, das natürlich, ja.
...Gästebücher.
Hallo, schöne Webseite hast du, Knuddel.
Oder so ein dummes Zeug, Alter.
Oh Mann.
...Bücher.
Eine andere Antiquität, die wir alle an unseren Webseiten in den 90ern hatten, war natürlich das Gästebuch.
Ich erinnere mich, dass ich meine Gästebücher hundertmal jeden Tag beobachte.
Und die Idee war, dass jedes Mal, wenn ein neuer Besucher auf deinem Website kam,
dann würden sie dir eine kleine Note geben, um dir zu sagen, was sie über es gedacht haben.
Und du könntest sie auch ein paar Fragen stellen, die sie auch da haben.
...Wie attraktiv sind deine Gästebücher?
Was? Was? Was?
Was? CDU an die What?
Alles klar.
...Wollte ein kleines statue über einen Community найти und auch ein kleines Geschenkkeeper des Hangars hinzufügen.
Jetzt, dass unsere Webseiten mit sozialen Medien kommentieren, sind die Gästebücher nicht mehr notwendig.
Aber sie waren ein wirklich tuerer Weg, diese Zahlen zu übersetzen, die du auf deinem HIT-Kanal gesehen hast,
das oft nahe an deinem Gästebuch-Link auf deiner Webseite steht, in die Leute einzulassen.
Und du hättest sie oft für ihre Beziehung und einen Kommentar fragen, und es war wirklich cool,
diese Leute von überall um die Welt zu sehen.
Ja.
...und ihre persönlichen Webseiten überlaufen.
Website and taking the time to leave you a comment.
And I was really pleased to see that the retro-themed Captain Marvel Website that Marvel set up
last year included a guestbook for that real 90s authenticity.
And number one, the sense of community.
Ganz ehrlich, die Sachen sind viel zu high-res.
Authenticity.
And number one, the sense of community.
Das stimmt.
Das trifft aber auch auf sehr vieles zu.
Das trifft vor allem auf Oldschool-MMOs zu.
Heute sind MMOs verkommen zu einem Solo-Crime mit ab und zu Discord-Call für irgendwelche Raids.
Das war ganz andere Games damals.
Also, MMOs von damals waren eher...
Das war quasi Fantasy-Welt mit Social Simulator.
Das war ein großer Chatraum im Endeffekt.
Ein großer Chatraum mit Gameplay.
Mit, wie ich finde, Gameplay, was es heute immer noch kein zweites Mal gibt.
Deswegen spiele ich auch immer noch Dark auf dem Freeshot.
Seit 20 Jahren spiele ich das immer wieder.
Das dürfte mit Abstand das Game sein, wo ich wirklich mit riesigem Abstand die meiste Spielzeit drin habe.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das...
Das muss man schon in Jahren messen, meine Spielzeit da drin.
Wenn es reicht.
Welches Game?
Dark.
Dark Age of Camelot.
Spiele ich immer noch auf dem Freeshot.
Kam 2001 oder so raus.
Da habe ich tausende Stunden Spielzeit.
Ganz ehrlich, es gab damals weniger Spasten.
Nein, also weniger Arschlöcher.
Ich glaube, das lag ein bisschen daran.
Wobei man sagen muss...
Okay, man kann nicht sagen, dass es weniger Arschlöcher online gab.
Es gab damals schon auch richtig viele nervige Leute.
Der Durchschnitts-IQ war höher.
Ich glaube, das konnte man sagen.
Weil...
Und dementsprechend war das Arschloch-Verhalten ein bisschen...
Wie soll man sagen?
Ein bisschen...
Advanceter.
Vielleicht als heute vielleicht.
Und das lag einfach daran,
weil alleine schon die Computer- und Internetbenutzung
schwieriger war wie heute.
Da konntest du nicht, wenn du einfach nur...
Wenn das Höchste der Gefühle, was du konntest, ist...
Also vom geistlichen Anspruch her, ist dein Namenschreiben.
Wenn du mehr nicht hinkriegst,
hattest du keine Chance.
Also wenn das quasi die geistigste Höchstleistung ist,
die du vollbringen kannst,
dass du mit Ach und Krach deinen Namen aufschreiben kannst,
irgendwie so halbwegs,
dann konntest du das...
Und das kriegen ja manche Leute dann richtig hin.
Ich sag nur, ich muss nicht schreiben können,
weil mein Mann kann das.
Da war nichts mit Internet damals.
Und dementsprechend hattest du damals
ein Publikum im Internet,
was etwas schlauer als der Durchschnitt war.
Es waren nicht wenige Arschlöcher,
aber es war auf...
Es war ein bisschen advanceder alles, ja.
Da wurde nicht die Mutter beleidigt,
sondern du wurdest beleidigt,
aber auf schlauere Art und Weise.
Also das Klientel im Internet war anders damals, auf jeden Fall.
Ich hatte ganz viele Leute,
die ich aus Dark kannte damals.
Und den Fabian übrigens auch, ne?
Den kannte ich aus Dark.
Und Leute, mit denen ich teilweise heute noch unregelmäßig Kontakt hatte,
und Leute, mit denen ich teilweise heute noch unregelmäßig Kontakt hatte,
und Leute, mit denen ich teilweise auch noch unregelmäßig Kontakt hatte,
manche von denen kenn ich sogar offline.
Nicht viele, aber manche.
Tinder-Vision.
...Apps, Websites, Services wie Meetup,
die dir ermöglichen, Konferenzen in der realen Welt zu organisieren
und Real-Life-Meetups zu machen, über alles, was es geht.
Und dank der Macht,
Es sollte heutzutage eigentlich immer weniger required sein,
wenn man nicht irgendwelche Boomer-Chefs hat.
Ui.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Ja, nee, nicht wirklich.
Ich auch nicht.
Ja.
Das stimmt, es war Magic,
aber ich bräuchte es ehrlich gesagt nicht unbedingt.
Also, ich hätte keine Probleme,
wieder irgendwie 20 zu sein oder so,
wobei, das reicht ja gar nicht mal.
Es ist ja erst 2004, Alter.
Ich hätte auch keine Probleme, 15 zu sein,
aber please, mit Technologie von heute.
Die Technik und die Sachen von da,
so cool und neu das war,
also, es ist nix, wo ich jetzt sagen würde,
oh, das war jetzt ja, sag mal, objektiv so viel besser,
das brauche ich unbedingt wieder.
Ja, okay.
Selbstvererbernd.
Ja, aber war ein gutes Video, hat er gut zusammengefasst.
War viele Dinge dabei, die ich wieder erkannt habe.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
What is the smallest possible exit?
Mir wäre egal.
Der macht gute Videos.
Weiß nicht, ob mich die Hardware so sehr juckt.
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Ein, erstmal schon AliExpress,
RevLink, let's go.
Wie, warum?
Warum sehen die Gehäuse von den China-Chinesen-Dinger
immer so aus, als passen sie nicht richtig?
Vielleicht, mal gucken.
Ich bin ja immer interessiert dran,
was es so für neue Sachen gäbe,
was man sich daheim hinstellen könnte,
ohne es sich dann wirklich daheim hinzustellen,
was es so für neue Sachen gäbe,
Arsch-Linux, oh nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Von dem haben wir uns das letzte Mal das Video angeguckt,
wie er Linux ausprobiert hat.
Jetzt probiert er Arsch-Linux aus,
denn das muss heute nicht sein.
Guck mal hier.
Erster Co-Pilot plus, oh nee, nee, kein Bock.
Ein Schneiper.
Gehalt eines Scharfschützen der Bundeswehr.
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt.
Ich könnte wetten,
dass er 90% seines Tages nicht snipert.
Nicht sniper.
Das ist tatsächlich die alles entscheidende Frage, ob der Trickshotten kann.
The 16-Nose-Scope.
Hast du gesehen, dass Windows jetzt automatisch Sachen zu OneDrive hochlädt?
Nee, ich habe OneDrive nicht mal gestartet überhaupt.
Zeig mal, hast du mal einen Link irgendwie dazu?
OneDrive?
Achso, ich google.
Ist super.
Aha.
Microsoft OneDrive, heimliche Datensynchronisation oder falsch gelegt Medienberichtsfolge,
die Ordner-Synchronisation von OneDrive ungefragt zu aktivieren.
Alter, die gefacken mich so unglaublich ab.
Ich verwende diese Schrottbetriebssysteme eigentlich nur aus Gaming-Gründen.
Video, Stelz und weil ich dran gewöhnt bin.
Habe ich OneDrive überhaupt drauf?
Anscheinend. Kann man das aninstallen?
Nee, anscheinend nicht.
Kann man nicht aninstallen.
Wer seinen Rechner so einrichtet, wie Microsoft es sich wünscht, mit dem Internet verbunden an Microsoft...
Achso, ich bin ja nicht mehr mit einem Microsoft-Konto.
Erhalte dadurch etwa die Ordner-Desktop.
Ja, mein Desktop-Ordner ist voll mit allem Möglichen.
Alter, so ein Schrott.
Aber die facken mich unglaublich ab mit dem ganzen Krempel.
Es wird immer schwieriger, es in irgendeiner Art und Weise weiter zu rechtfertigen,
dass man dieses scheiß Betriebssystem weiterverwendet.
Oh.
Okay, lass uns mal gucken, was der Schneiper...
Was der Schneuper, was der so verdient.
Den größten Teil seines Tages wird er wahrscheinlich nicht snipern.
Windows 10 ist dieses Jahr EOL.
Nee.
Nächstes Jahr, oder?
Ja, nächstes Jahr.
Das ist wirklich so wie so eine kleine Jagd.
Als Soldat bist du natürlich unglaublich kreditwürdig.
Es kann natürlich sein, dass die Beobachter jetzt dann hier rumstochen werden, weil die hier was gesehen haben.
Du bist kreditwürdig?
Wieso?
Weil deine Chance zu sterben höher ist?
Oder meinte er das genauso?
Also ich würde jetzt hier schießen.
Inwiefern macht man sich darüber Gedanken, dass man wirklich ein Menschenleben auslöscht?
Zwei Gedanken tagtäglich macht man sich nicht.
Eins.
Aber jeder weiß, wenn es drauf ankommt...
Da hättest du auch viel zu tun.
...sein könnte.
Hi, ich bin der Philipp.
Ich bin 31 Jahre alt.
Ich bin Scharfschütze in der Bundeswehr.
Und ihr dürft mich heute begleiten in der Bayerwald-Kaserne in Regen.
Der Tag in der Bundeswehr beginnt so...
Schönes Mützchen auch.
Wenn man das Antreten gibt.
Beim Antreten wird die Vollzähligkeit festgestellt und dann die Punkte für den Tag bekannt gegeben.
So, guten Morgen miteinander.
Guten Morgen.
Gehen wir zu der Vollzähligkeit ohne hier einen Dienstgrad.
Hier.
Scharfschütze zu sein ist ja quasi eine Spezialisierung.
Ich bin ja trotzdem Panzergrenadier mit der Spezialisierung, mein G22 zu nutzen.
Morgen.
Also ich habe hier ein Bett.
Da ich Heimschläfer bin, fahre ich jeden Tag nach Hause, so wie der Name schon sagt.
Außer wenn natürlich so Nachtausbildungen sind, dann schlafe ich natürlich hier, wenn es mal länger geht.
Das ist quasi der Auftrag für heute.
Später werden da die Koordinaten bekannt gegeben, auf die ich mich dann quasi annähern muss.
Jetzt gehen wir runter vor die Waffenkammer.
Jeder Scharfschütze hat sein persönliches Scharfschützengewehr.
Also das ist sein Gewehr, das ist sein Material.
Und das muss er auch sauber machen und alles, hä?
Gut, da haben wir das Gewehr.
Am Tag für die Waffe investiere ich eine halbe Stunde.
Das ist das Magazin.
Den brauche ich dann nachher, um die Waffe zu laden.
Jeder Soldat trägt mindestens 15.000 Euro mit sich rum.
Der Rucksack sollte jetzt ein Mindestgewicht von 20 Kilo haben.
Also die Waffe allein, da sprechen wir schon von 12,5 Kilo.
Man gewöhnt sich irgendwann an das Gewicht.
Da musst du vor allem auch richtig fit sein.
Mein Auftrag ist es heute, mich unentdeckt an ein Ziel anzunähern, einen Schuss abzugeben
und bestmöglich wieder unentdeckt nach Schussabgabe zurück in die Kaserne zurückzukommen.
Das ist das Wichtigste, um das Ziel zu verlegen.
Boah, lass mich am besten hier hin.
Jetzt würde ich als erstes Gesichtstarnung anlegen.
Das Wichtigste ist auf jeden Fall, dass das hellige Gesicht...
Es ist mit einem Kamerateam dabei sicherlich enorm unauffällig.
...dunkel wird.
Das ist zumindest das A und O.
So, sieht's gut aus oder nicht?
Ich sammle jetzt erstmal Tarnmaterial zusammen.
Mein Ziel ist es, meinen Tarnanzug jetzt so zu verschleiern mit Tanne,
dass mich dann später die Beobachter im Tannenwald nicht aufklären können.
Auch wenn das jetzt hier quasi eine Übung ist.
Eine gewisse Ernsthaftigkeit sollte bei jedem...
Müssen die das echt selbst bauen?
Ich dachte, die bringen sich irgendeinen Anzug mit.
...hier sein.
Im Endeffekt, wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, du musst da vorne jemanden rausnehmen,
dann ist das ein Leben, das du quasi dann nimmst.
So ein Fall kann eintreten.
Ist ja nicht so, als wenn das jetzt nicht präsent wäre, das ganze Thema.
Ich kann den Kompass jetzt zu Hilfe nehmen.
Ja, letztendlich, so blöd's klingt, ist sein Job.
Ich glaube, wenn du dir dann den ganzen Tag drüber Gedanken machst,
dann kannst du sowas nicht machen.
Wir haben ungefähr einen Kilometer, den wir gehen müssen.
Das probiere ich, wie John Wick, mit einem einzelnen Schwung.
Ach, der hat seinen geupgradet.
Okay.
Wir bilden das Szenario aus, dass irgendwo eine Kommunikationsanlage
mit mehreren Leuten besetzt ist, wo wir uns dann unentdeckt annähern müssen,
die quasi dann rausnehmen oder ausschalten müssen.
Jetzt kommt ein relativ offenes Gelände, das wir überspringen müssen.
Wir könnten von links und rechts eingesehen werden.
Das heißt, Taschen checken und dann mit Sprint, sag ich mal, so schnell wie möglich rüber.
Das ist wirklich wie so eine kleine Jagd.
Das ist ähnlich, wie wenn man beim Versteckenspielen irgendwo liegt
und dann jemand in der Nähe ist und man dann...
Der muss ja wirklich für sein Geld auf was arbeiten, so ist es nicht.
Und so denkt, oh mein Gott, hoffentlich erwischt er mich nicht.
So leichtes Adrenalin, würde ich sagen.
Hier gibt es keinen Schusskanal auf einer anständigen Höhe.
Ich müsste bis zum Waldrand nach vorne gehen, um einen Blick auf die Freifläche zu kriegen.
Also es ist nicht einfach so drauf losschießen.
Wir haben jetzt das Ziel gesehen und ich stelle jetzt die Waffe auf und schieße einfach.
Nein, wir müssen, wie gesagt, noch diesen Schusskanal generieren.
So nah an der Freifläche ist halt...
Erst mal Predator-Ruf.
...eher so tief wie möglich im Raum.
Oder gleich AC-130.
Ich werde halt auch dazu nochmal sein ganzes Gerämpel aufnehmen.
Und immer nochmal probieren, bis man halt irgendwann mal eine Möglichkeit findet.
So im Gegensatz zur ersten Stellung ist es hier viel angenehmer, viel dunkler.
Ich wette, der hardscoped, Leute.
Also...
Das ist ja eigentlich Low-Skill, ne?
Klar.
Es könnte jetzt jederzeit sein, dass die mich irgendwie sehen.
Ja.
Warum ist das kein Dragon-Scale-Scan auf der Sniper?
Da habe ich vorne an meinem ZF das Glas nicht sauber abgedeckt.
Und die Spiegelung hat dann quasi...
...mich verraten.
Guck mal, wie krass er...
Ne, sehe ich so.
Aha, okay.
Ich muss definitiv höher.
Das ist so die Erkenntnis gerade.
Sieht gut aus.
Also ich würde jetzt hier schießen.
Dazu tane ich als nächstes alles ab.
Und werde wahrscheinlich vielleicht noch eins, zwei Äste vorne wegknipsen.
Und dann werde ich hier schießen.
Inwiefern macht man sich darüber Gedanken, dass man wirklich ein Menschenleben auch auslöscht?
Also Gedanken tagtäglich macht man sich nicht.
Aber jeder weiß, wenn es darauf ankommt, dass es so sein könnte, dass was passiert.
Es gehört zu seinem Job dabei.
Und ich bin der Meinung, wir brauchen so Leute.
Wenn alle friedlich wären, klar.
Könntest du...
Wenn alle Leute friede, Freude, Eierkuchen mäßig drauf wären.
Heuchze kein Militär und keine Polizei.
Dass das nicht so ist, sieht man aber oft genug.
Und klar, kostet Geld.
Aber...
...wenn man es braucht, ist...
Haben besser als brauchen.
Dass du halt dann deinen Job erledigen musst.
Der im Zweifel heißt?
Jemanden zu töten, ja.
Genau, wir haben 260 Meter.
Drei, zwei, eins...
Also entdeckt haben die uns jetzt nicht.
Jetzt als nächstes kommt quasi der Läufer, der das Gewehr prüft.
Im Ernstfall werden die Beobachter nicht mit einem Fernglas hier reinschauen,
sondern mit irgendeinem MG oder was hier reinholzen.
Wir müssen hier was sehen.
Der Pfeil soll quasi den Schuss darstellen.
Was?
Das schaut schon mal gut aus.
Das habe ich nicht gecheckt.
Das passt nicht.
Das habe ich nicht kapiert.
Also, okay.
Die merken jetzt, dass sie beschossen werden.
Und die ballern halt einfach mal wild so grob in die Richtung zurück.
Von wo sie denken, dass der Schuss gekommen ist.
Aber woher will der Typ mit dem...
Mit dem Pähnchen das wissen?
Ah, ach so.
Ach, das war aus der Sicht des Trucks.
Okay, das war...
Der Typ mit der Fahne hat quasi auf der anderen Seite gewedelt,
wo sie denken, wo sie hinschießen würden.
Das ist auch...
Gewehr bleibt auch von alleine stehen.
Auch die Wichtigkeit dann.
In dem Fall war es ein guter Durchgang.
Es war auf jeden Fall fordernd.
Also es war kein leichter Durchgang.
Besonders, ihr habt es ja gemerkt,
wie ich erst auf der ganz anderen Seite war.
Wie ich bis hierher gekommen bin.
Mit Rucksack aufnehmen wieder.
Da irgendwo rumgleiten und so weiter.
Also, das gehört dazu.
Angefangen hat das Ganze mit einem qualifizierenden Hauptschulabschluss.
Ich bin danach in eine Kochausbildung gegangen.
Hab auch nebenbei noch bei...
Das kannst du voll vergessen, den zu sehen, ne?
Pakete in Container verbracht.
Beides zusammen hat einfach nicht genug Geld gebracht.
Und als junger Kerl möchtest du ja dann trotzdem mal was leisten.
Und da ich schon immer irgendwie einen Bezug zur Bundeswehr hatte,
dachte ich mir, okay, probier ich das Ganze mal.
Also definitiv ist es ein Kulturschock.
Weil dann dieses ganze Strenge,
diese ganzen Formulierungen, sag ich mal.
Das Antreten in der Früh.
Da ist schon ein gewisser Wechsel da vom Zivilen ins Militärische.
Das muss man auch mögen.
Also diese weiße Tüte ist sozusagen der Verpflegungsbeutel.
Das Marschpaket.
Da sind zum Beispiel halt Wraps drin oder Sandwiches.
Das ist quasi für die Verpflegung draußen.
Als nächstes machen wir die Beobachtungsübung.
Die führen wir jetzt durch.
Zeit dafür haben die Kameraden...
Also der muss ja wirklich was arbeiten für sein Geld.
60 Minuten.
In 60 Minuten haben die die Möglichkeit,
bis zu 10 Gegenstände im Gelände zu finden.
Im Gelände können zum Beispiel ein Nagel sein,
eine Granate, die irgendwo halb verdeckt liegt.
Ein Nagel?
Wir werden nichts offen liegen lassen,
sondern wir verstecken das Ganze.
Wie willst du denn einen Nagel finden?
Der kann ja irgendwo verbuddelt sein.
Geht nochmal die ganzen markanten Stellen ab.
Also in der Wiese braucht man natürlich jetzt nichts suchen.
Aber vielleicht einfach mal dieses Objekt genauer betrachten.
Vielleicht passt da ja irgendwas von der Farbe nicht rein.
Wir gehen jetzt schon mal runter,
um euch dann anschließend das ganze Lagebild aufzulösen.
Ich bin jetzt beim ersten Gegenstand.
Ein Handapparat, der jetzt hier rumgewickelt ist.
Okay, jetzt haben wir gerade gehört,
dass sie diesen Gegenstand gefunden haben.
Das soll quasi das Auge halt schulen,
dass das Ding halt nicht in das Gelände oder das Objekt passt.
Hier kommen wir zum nächsten Gegenstand.
Das ist jetzt ein Batteriebehälter.
Hier haben wir ein MG-Patronengurt.
Mehr in der Beobachtungsübung gibt es eigentlich nicht mehr.
In der Beobachtungsübung gibt es eigentlich nichts zu erzählen.
Also es geht einfach nur darum, so genau wie möglich zu arbeiten.
Nachbereiten ist insofern notwendig.
Ich möchte natürlich mit der Waffe lang genug arbeiten.
Da gehört zum Beispiel immer das Einölen des Rohres nach Schussabgabe dazu.
Also das ist was, was ich super nervig finde,
also generell finde, sich um so Maintenance-Sachen zu kümmern.
Aber in dem Fall, ganz ehrlich,
ich glaube, es gibt nichts Besseres,
als darauf zu achten, dass dein Gewehr funktioniert.
Weil im Zweifelsfall bist du halt am Arsch,
wenn es nicht funktioniert.
Also das ist so.
Nicht nur, weil es Vorschrift ist,
sondern es ist wahrscheinlich echt auch in einem eigenen,
besten Selbstinteresse, dass das funktioniert.
Wir bekommen jeden Monat 3.200 Euro Grundgehalt mit Amtszulage.
Und davon bleiben wir im Monat dann 2.700 Euro netto.
Ich zahle keine Krankenversicherung,
keine Rentenversicherung, keine Arbeitslosenversicherung.
Von der Krankenversicherung bin ich befreit,
weil wir als Soldaten in der freien Heilfürsorge gelistet sind.
Nach Verlassen der Bundeswehr wird die Rente nachgezahlt von der Bundeswehr.
Mein Gehalt, was ich aktuell bekomme,
also ich bin vollumfänglich zufrieden damit.
Weil man darf nicht vergessen,
man macht ja zum Beispiel als Soldat auch während der Dienstzeit Sport.
Das sind alles so Vorzüge, die man auch hat.
Von der Bayerwald-Kaserne bin ich 30 km entfernt.
Das sind roundabout 20 Minuten Fahrzeit.
Hallöchen.
Ich wohne hier mit meiner Freundin in der 80-qm-Wohnung.
Als Soldat bist du natürlich unglaublich kreditwürdig.
Das heißt, ein SRZ 12 oder was,
da sollte eigentlich fast nichts im Weg stehen.
Aktuell bin ich auch noch der Meinung,
dass eine zweite Wohnung gut wäre.
Also ich würde mir jetzt dann noch eine zweite Wohnung kaufen,
eine neue Immobilie.
Dahin möchte ich investieren.
Aktuell in der Zeit überall loderts.
Und es ist halt überall gefährlich.
Und man hofft halt nur, dass es nicht zum Ernstfall kommt.
Da kriegt man schon ein bisschen Angst.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Als ich zur Bundeswehr gegangen bin, war schon immer klar,
okay, wenn was passiert, dann muss ich irgendwo hin.
Es ist jetzt alles näher und präsenter.
Aber ich bin ja Soldat.
Das heißt quasi, mir ist bewusst, es kann jederzeit was passieren.
Ich muss gleich weiter zum Breakdance-Training.
Noch nicht genug Sport gemacht.
Reinspaziert. Hallöchen.
Was geht?
Ja, und das ist unser Trainingsraum.
Okay, der Move wird folgendermaßen sein.
Wir brauchen diesen Kick hier.
Tankstand und Welle.
Toss, Toss, Musik.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Alter, da geht er richtig ab, der Typ.
Das freut mich einfach unheimlich,
dass ich sowohl als Hilfsausbilder bei den Scharfschützen
als auch als Breakdance-Tanzlehrer
den Leuten einfach ein bisschen an die Hand nehme
und möchte, dass die besser werden.
Toss, Toss, Toss.
Geht doch klar, oder?
Trickshots quasi, ja.
Es geht doch voll klar.
So, ihr habt mich heute begleitet.
Ein Tag als Scharfschützen der Bundeswehr.
Für weitere LSD-Bundeswehr-Videos
klickt ihr hier.
Für alle anderen weiteren Jobs
LSD-Videos.
Lohnt sich das?
Ja, vielleicht nicht die taktisch
geschickteste Abkürzung.
Tactical.
Der war richtig Tactical, der Typ.
Wollte mir bei Amazon letztens
eine Axt für den Garten kaufen.
Und was wird mir empfohlen?
Ein Tactical Tomahawk.
Anstatt eine normale Axt, die ich brauche.
Es ist mittlerweile, was sie da kaufen,
ist alles Tactical.
Tactical Taschennampe, Tactical Knife,
Tactical Tomahawk,
Tactical Kappe,
Tactical Schuhe, alles Tactical.
Ja, Tactical Besteck und so
gibt's bestimmt auch alles. Alles Tactical.
Tactical Nuke.
Gut, gibt's Sachen,
die kannst du auf Amazon nicht kaufen.
Noch nicht, wer weiß.
Was wird dir da angezeigt?
Wo denn? Was ist denn hier unten?
Tutorial auf Deutsch.
Installation
und Anwendung.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Hackerman Zeugs wird mir da angezeigt.
Irgendwie interessiert mich die
Hardwarekiste.
Amazon gibt's das auch, okay.
Oder auch nicht.
Irgendwie interessiert mich das,
was da drin ist.
Ne, ich hab mir bei Amazon eine Axt gekauft.
Und kein Tactical Tomahawk.
Wir haben einen .
Er ist bestimmt für neuere
Generation, also für Refresh.
Vermute ich
jetzt einfach mal.
Und dann haben wir noch
3, 5, 5...
Die sind langsamer.
Alter, die Benahmung, Mann.
Das ist ja mal
ein Produktbezeichnung, oder?
Q20331G9C3758R
So würde ich
meine Spülmaschine auch benennen, wenn ich
eine bauen würde.
Das ist aber das Falsche.
Was der hier verlinkt hat.
Irgendwas anderes.
Ja doch.
Die liefern nicht nach Germany.
Warum nicht?
Was hat denn das Teil hier zu bieten?
Gucke mal, das hat 5x2,5G.
4xSFP+.
Würde ich
jetzt mal vermuten, weil ansonsten macht's wenig Sinn.
Und
von der CPU würde ich sagen, ist das irgendein
Intel Low Power
Atom oder sowas.
Warum liefern die nicht mal nach Germany?
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Du hast M2 Slots drinnen.
Atom mit 8
Kernen aus 2020.
Ja, aber das reicht ja für das meiste, was du machen willst.
Die restliche Sache, ich meine,
wenn das 320 Steuer...
Die restliche Sache sind mega nice.
Du hast Crypto Extensions.
8 Kerne.
2xSFP+.
Das ist nicht
übel.
Für irgendeine Homeserver-Geschichte.
Das ist viel besser als
Virtualisierungs-Node unten drunter.
Zumal du anscheinend M2 SSDs einbauen kannst.
Aber
gut, man kriegt's ja hier eh nicht.
Also müssen wir uns das jetzt auch nicht angucken.
Läuft
OpenSense auf ARM?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Was, deswegen liefert AliExpress nicht mehr?
Was ist das?
Gemäß der neuen Verpackungsverordnung
des Ministeriums für Klimaschutz
müssten ausländische Versandteile
künftig in Österreich... Okay, das ist jetzt für Österreich.
Aber wahrscheinlich in Deutschland ähnlich.
Einen eigenen Verpackungsbev... Einen was?
Oh Mann,
Alter, wie viel Bürokratie-Scheiß
überall am Laufen ist, Mann.
Wie viel
Bürokratie möchten sie haben? Alles.
Wie sollen das denn
0815 China-Chinesen
AliExpress-3-Mann-Laden?
Wie stellen die sich das vor?
Aber mal ganz davon abgesehen,
warum interessiert die das überhaupt?
Die scheißen doch auch sonst auf alles.
Was so Vorgaben angeht.
Na gut, die scheißen so lange drauf,
wie man es einfach durchkommt, ohne dass die Pakete...
solange die Pakete ankommen.
Oh Mann.
Please, Mitteilung über SFP.
Ah ja.
Haben wir sonst so irgendwas?
Ey, die Artstellungsexperience will ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Was ist das?
Verwaltung trifft Hochleistung.
Thüringen ist neues Landesrechenzentrum.
Oh, das ist doch bestimmt...
Das ist doch bestimmt wieder...
irgendein...
Wir zeigen, wie toll wir sind
und im Endeffekt kommt nix bei raus, oder?
Most popular Web-Servers.
Okay,
ich hoffe mal...
Okay, ich predikte.
Ich predikte mal, dass...
Okay.
Was sind die meistbenutzten Web-Server
jetzt?
Also ich predikte mal, was am Ende rauskommt.
Nginx
und Apache sind vorne.
IIS
wird wahrscheinlich noch irgendwo drin sein.
Auch wenn ich es nicht verstehen kann,
wer allen Ernstes
IIS verwendet.
Dazu denke ich, dass auch noch ein paar
weitverbreitete Framework-Web-Server
drin sein würden.
Also ich denke mal, dass eventuell
sowas wie
der Node.js
Web-Server dabei ist.
Also quasi das, was Express und so verwendet.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass
so die Springboot-Geschichte
und so, wie auch immer das
nach außen aussieht und so dabei ist.
Kestrel könnte vielleicht dabei sein.
Das ist der C-Sharp-Web-Server.
Bei Go bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Also ich tippe mal drauf.
Es ist Nginx,
Apache,
leider noch irgendwo in den Top 10
IIS.
Springboot-Gedöns.net
Event.net
tippe ich mal und...
Ja, Node.js.
Also Express und so Gedöns.
Okay, mal schauen, ob ich recht habe.
Alter.
Ultramotivationsmusik?
Gut, wir sind im Jahr 1993.
Ja, dass da der originale
CERN-HTTPD läuft.
Übrigens, deswegen heißen so Sachen
heute auf Red Hat immer noch
HTTPD, obwohl es ein Apache ist.
Äh...
Also das wundert mich jetzt nicht.
Wir sind...
Weit vor Mainstream-Internet.
So.
So, jetzt dürfte
es so langsam,
aber sicher
die Zeit sein, wo ich zum ersten
Mal über Modem
im Internet war.
So in dem Dreh,
würde ich mal sagen.
Sun Oracle.
Apache. Apache gibt es ewig
schon, ja.
Zeus habe ich noch nie gehört.
Da ist er.
Keck Windows.
Das andere Zeug kenne ich nicht.
Apache geht steil und IIS geht steil.
Wie war damals?
Ich habe damals schon nicht genau gecheckt,
warum die Leute ernsthaft so scharf drauf waren,
ihren Krempel unter IIS laufen zu lassen.
Xitami und so ist noch nie gehört.
Apache, da muss ich immer dran denken,
an die alten PHP Tutorials.
Da musstest du unter Windows
immer XAMPP installieren. Kennt das noch jemand?
XAMPP.
Da hast du dann im Endeffekt
Apache und MySQL
unter Windows am Start gebracht.
XAMPP.
Das kommt von Exchange?
Das könnte natürlich sein.
PHP MyAdmin ist richtig krasses
Hackertool, haben wir ja letztens gelernt.
Berufsschule.
Berufsschule ist normal, dass sie 20 Jahre outdated sind.
Ach, Netscape wurde von
Oracle gepurchased. Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Netscape Enterprise Server.
Und dann
haben sie es wahrscheinlich vor die Wand gefahren.
So Oracle typisch.
Ja, sieht so aus.
Ups.
Zeus.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ohne Scheiß, wenn ich
das hier sehe, die Schriftart und alles,
schreit aber irgendwie Microsoft.
Wollte keiner zahlen. Ja, das kann sein.
Apache, damals auch schon Open Source.
Habe ich nie gehört.
Alternative
zu IIS für Windows-Users.
Also quasi eine Nische
in der Nische.
Frag mich, wann Nginx dabei kommt.
Das kann nicht mehr so lange dauern,
weil ich kann mich daran erinnern,
als ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe, also irgendwie 2007,
da war Nginx schon ein Ding.
Das gab es da schon, wenn ich mich
jetzt nicht total vertue.
Was durchaus sein kann.
Ah, jetzt,
okay, jetzt kommt Java Gedöns.
Jetzt kommt Java Gedöns.
Gibt es
gleich ein Update zu deinem Fahrrad und dem Anwalt.
Ist jetzt, ja, es ist alles Geld da.
Nach, nach, nach
fast einem, nein, nicht ganz, aber
nach einem Dreivierteljahr.
Also nach 10 Monaten oder so.
Krass, oder?
Dass das so lange gedauert hat.
Bis ich das ganze Geld für mein Fahrrad habe wieder.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Das ist
ja ein Video, das lässt sich super
unterbrechen.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Seit gestern
ist mein
Garmin-Tracker der Meinung,
ich bin überdurchschnittlich
trainiert, guck mal.
Ich bin jetzt in Top 40%
für mein Gender und Age.
Easy, ich könnte einfach
mein Gender ändern, dann wäre ich in Top 30 oder so.
Ich bin jetzt
offiziell
besser als der Durchschnitt in meinem Alter.
Warum meint er das?
Weil,
weil der der Meinung ist,
ich habe ein Cycling
V2 Max von 45.
Das ist so ganz grob gesagt.
Ich bin ja da auch nicht so 100%
wissenschaftlich voll dabei.
Das ist so ein grober,
das ist ein Wert dafür, wieviel Sauerstoff
du quasi in Energie umsetzen kannst.
Ja.
Mein Running V2 Max ist tatsächlich
ein bisschen niedriger.
Der ist glaube ich gerade bei 43.
Warum auch immer das so.
Das mag daran liegen,
dass ich noch nicht so lange mit Wattmesser
fahre.
Beim Fahrrad,
dass ich das jetzt erst einpendeln muss.
Vielleicht geht es ja auch noch ein bisschen höher, keine Ahnung.
Also, das sagt zumindest mein
Fitnesstracker.
Was auch bedeutet, ich bin mit knapp
40 Jahren fitter, als ich jemals
in meinem Leben vorher gewesen bin.
Muss man auch erstmal auf die Reihe kriegen.
Und das Ding ist halt,
und das habe ich ja auch geschrieben,
also wenn ich das als Hackermans Kellerkind
auf die Reihe kriege, kann das potenziell jeder schaffen.
Natürlich
hatten wir jetzt schon wieder in den Kommentaren
ein paar Wichtigtuer,
die gesagt haben, und die haben Recht,
muss ich sagen, die haben Recht,
dass das rein mathematisch gesehen natürlich nicht geht,
weil wenn es jeder schaffen würde,
dann wäre der Durchschnitt höher.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Rein mathematisch gesehen ist das
falsch, was ich geschrieben habe.
Aber nachdem ja nicht jeder das probieren
wird, jeder der es
probiert und dabei bleibt, kann es schaffen.
Also wie gesagt,
ich bin das beste Beispiel für,
ich habe mit knapp 40 angefangen,
also mit 39,
oder naja, mit 38
muss es dann gewesen sein, vor einem Jahr,
weil ich bin ja noch 39,
habe ich angefangen,
ein bisschen mehr Sport zu machen,
und nach knapp einem Jahr sieht es jetzt ganz gut aus.
Und wenn ich das auf die Reihe kriege,
kann man das potenziell schaffen.
Das Wichtigste daran ist eigentlich nur,
und das habe ich auch gemerkt,
gar nicht mal so sehr,
es ist nicht sinnvoll,
es so all out voll zu übertreiben.
Das Wichtigste ist wirklich konstant
was zu machen.
Und das muss auch nicht jedes Mal
super anstrengend sein.
Wie sagen die ganzen
Sport,
wie heißt denn das so, Trainingswissenschaft,
Trainingsforscher,
die sagen ja 80-20.
Ja, bei Profis 90-10,
aber bei normalen Dudes wie uns,
bei normalen Leuten
wie uns 80-20, also sollst
80%
easy machen und 20%
richtig heftig.
Ich bin 39 aktuell.
Und das Wichtigste
ist tatsächlich konstant was zu machen.
Mittlerweile ist es so, als ich angefangen habe,
also rein
von meinem Fitnessalter
bin ich tatsächlich etwas rückwärts gealtert
das letzte Jahr über.
Übrigens hier,
das ist so ganz
grob gesagt ein Wert
dafür, wie viel Sauerstoff du zu
Energie umwandeln kannst,
zu Leistungsoutput umwandeln kannst.
Hier gibt es wahrscheinlich
noch eine bessere Erklärung.
Die maximale Sauerstoffaufnahme
gibt an, wie viel
Milliliter Sauerstoff der Körper
im Zustand der Ausbelastung
maximal, was zum Teufel.
Also es ist im Prinzip ein grober Wert dafür
oder zumindest
bei mir ist es ein grober Wert, weil es ist ja aus der App,
das ist ja nicht wirklich gemessen jetzt mit irgendeiner
Sauerstoffmaske und Blutabnahme und sonst was.
Das ist ein Wert dafür,
wie viel du quasi an
Sauerstoff in Energie umwandeln kannst.
Also quasi alles.
Du brauchst halt alles dazu.
Du brauchst Lungenkapazität,
du brauchst Sauerstoffaufnahme ins Blut,
du brauchst Herzkreislauf
und du brauchst Muskelkraft
im Endeffekt, um das
dann auch in Leistungsoutput umwandeln zu können.
Also das heißt, das ist quasi so ein
recht guter allgemeiner Fitnesswert,
weil der das alles widerspiegelt,
was in der Kette beteiligt
ist von, ich atme Sauerstoff,
ich atme Sauerstoff ein und
drück
Leistung in meine Pedale rein.
Hast du auch so eine Rolle für zu Hause?
Habe ich, habe ich.
Ich habe aber keine Rolle für zu Hause.
Ich habe einen
Wahoo Kickr Smart Trainer.
Den verwende ich aber nur im Winter.
Ja.
Und das wirklich
das mit Abstand wichtigste ist,
konstant was zu machen.
Und es muss nicht konstant
anstrengend sein.
Nicht, wenn es konstant anstrengend ist,
weil dann steigt
die Chance, dass dir das Bein weh tut.
Und wenn du weiter rennst, wenn dir das Bein weh tut, tut dir das Bein
noch mehr weh und irgendwann ist irgendwas kaputt.
Und wichtig ist, dass man
konstant was macht. Das ist echt mit
Abstand das Wichtigste. Also wenn
ihr jetzt jemand habt, der
dreimal die Woche
was macht,
nach dem super ausgeklügelten
High IQ Trainingsplan
versus einen,
der sechsmal die Woche was macht,
einfach nur planlos,
dann wird trotzdem der, der sechsmal
die Woche was macht, auch wenn es planlos ist,
besser sein, als der, der nur dreimal
was macht. Umso
konstanter das ist und umso
ausführlicher man das macht, umso wichtiger wird es
natürlich, dass man ein bisschen Hirn macht, aber
insgesamt ist echt mit Abstand das
Wichtigste, dass man was macht.
Ich habe angefangen mit
so zwei, dreimal die Woche
hier so ein bisschen
rumlaufen.
Und ich habe damit auch ehrlich gesagt
nur angefangen, weil ich wissen wollte,
Max, kriegst du denn überhaupt, wie viel,
wie viel am Stück kannst du denn rennen, ohne dass du kaputt bist?
Und nachdem
ich das dann gemacht habe, habe ich festgestellt, ey, das geht
ja deutlich besser als gedacht und dann habe ich einfach
weitergemacht. Und
angefangen so mit zwei, dreimal die Woche einfach
nur hier so ein bisschen rumrennen und
ich habe ganz am Anfang auch diesen Fehler gemacht,
den wahrscheinlich viele machen, dass ich
jedes Mal, wenn ich rennen gegangen bin,
bin ich all out
und dann bin ich wieder
Pulle losgerannt.
Das geht mit zwei, dreimal die Woche auch noch ganz gut,
weil man hat immer mal eins, zwei Tage so Pause,
wo man dann mal nix und dann ist man soweit wieder ausgeruht
und soweit haben sich die Beine erholt.
Aber ich hatte damals auch schon am Anfang das Problem,
dass mir einfach übelst die
Schienbeine wehgetan haben.
Ich meine, damals war ich noch ein paar Kilo schwerer,
jetzt wiege ich ungefähr 88 Kilo bei 1,74.
Ich bin immer noch zu dick.
Also wir haben übelst die Schienbeine wehgetan.
Das hat gerade so sich ausgegangen,
dass ich beim nächsten Mal rennen wieder gesagt habe, ey,
geht wieder halbwegs.
Und ich bin wirklich dann zwei, dreimal die Woche all out
so schnell wie es ging gerannt
und das hat natürlich auch richtig was gebracht
am Anfang, weil von nicht trainiert so ein bisschen
geht halt richtig gut.
Und irgendwann habe ich dann gecheckt,
dass es aber eigentlich viel besser ist.
Man macht mehr,
aber nicht so anstrengend.
Und mittlerweile ist es tatsächlich so,
ich mache fast jeden Tag was
und ich mache nur Pause,
wenn es zu anstrengend gewesen ist
oder wenn ich merke, ey,
geht es nicht.
Und der überwiegende Teil dessen
ist tatsächlich
relativ,
relativ easy.
Relativ easy heißt bei mir,
das ist mittlerweile so
6 Minuten
45,
6 Minuten 50
pro Kilometer beim
Rennen, beim Laufen.
Hast du noch Muskelkater?
Ich habe nicht mehr
diesen,
wie soll man das beschreiben?
Ich habe nicht mehr diesen klassischen
Muskelkater, wo du dann quasi
dein Bein bewegst und denkst so
boah, alter.
Das habe ich nicht, ich habe aber heute beispielsweise,
also heute merke ich es immer noch in den Oberschenkeln
nach, ich bin gestern wieder zwei Stunden
Fahrrad gefahren,
ich merke das schon noch in den Oberschenkeln
und gerade beim Treppe runterlaufen merkt man es auch schon,
aber es ist nicht mehr dieses,
dieses beißende,
dieser beißende Muskelkater, sondern eher
so ein, boah, gestern war aber echt anstrengend,
ich merke es noch in den Beinen, Muskelkater.
Also nicht mehr dieses,
dieses, oh, ich habe diesen Muskel,
ich wusste, also ursprünglicher Muskelkater,
den man hat,
wenn man anfängt, ist Muskelkater
in Stellen, wo du nicht wusstest, dass du Muskeln hattest.
So.
Moment, da habe ich auch Muskeln?
Das ist es nicht mehr.
Es ist eher, ja,
so dass du merkst, ey, gestern, gestern
war anstrengend. Ja, und
seitdem ich das mache,
habe ich jetzt auch, sehe ich auch in meiner Fitness-App,
es geht wirklich richtig
steil nach oben. Also seitdem
ich wirklich jeden Tag
was mache, solange
es,
solange es geht, weil es nicht, weil
der Tag vorher nicht so anstrengend war,
das geht wirklich richtig steil nach oben.
Wenn ich jetzt in meine Garmin-App gucke,
also 4, das
hier, das ist ein Wert, der steigt irgendwie mal
alle paar Monate mal oder so,
wenn ich mal in meine Garmin-App gucke,
die haben hier, die haben beispielsweise was richtig cooles
drin, die haben
einen Race Predictor drin.
Die sagen dir dann quasi ungefähr,
was, was
die App denkt,
Suppenkuchen, danke für den Sub, massive
Subscription, danke schön.
Extrem nice.
Die haben einen Race Predictor drin,
die sagen dir quasi, was die App denkt,
anhand deiner Fitnesswerte, was du denn
schaffen kannst, bei
5 Kilometer,
10 Kilometer, 20 Kilometer und 40 Kilometer.
Und dazu,
was?
Das ist ein Screenshot von der Garmin-App,
die die Daten von meiner, von meiner
Uhr zählt.
Also, und hier hab ich, ich kann's,
ich kann's euch jetzt nicht zeigen, aber ich kann's euch, ich kann's euch
vorlegen, also, ich, wenn ich jetzt auf die letzten,
auf das letzte Jahr switche,
wenn ich auf das letzte Jahr switche,
da sieht man nämlich schön im Race Predictor,
was es denkt, was man packt, so.
Und ich hab angefangen,
also man sieht das,
richtig, das ist schwer
zu beschreiben, ich wüsste da, ich,
nee, nee, der Race Predictor ist
ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich gut in dem
was er prediktet, und
man sieht, dass es wirklich
konstant nach oben geht, es geht nicht,
also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es hier irgendwie
wirklich hier super, super stonkst,
exponentiell oder was auch immer nach oben geht,
es geht noch nicht mal, es geht linear nach
oben, noch, ja,
aber langsam,
linear nach oben, und
die letzten
paar Monate, die letzten paar Wochen tatsächlich
ein bisschen steiler, das liegt aber wahrscheinlich
auch daran, weil schöneres Wetter
ist, ja,
weil, ja,
zumindest, worauf ich, worauf ich raus will,
es hat
einen riesen Unterschied gemacht, seitdem ich angefangen
hab,
nee, nee, nee, nee, so schlimm ist es nicht
gewesen, ähm, seit
ich angefangen hab, tatsächlich
jetzt einfach konstant
regelmäßig, nicht,
nicht zwei-, dreimal die Woche, sondern
jeden Tag, sofern's nicht so anstrengend war, heute
weiß ich noch nicht, ob ich was mache, vielleicht geh ich heute Nachmittag
noch mal eine kleine Runde rennen,
langsam zum, zum Erholen, ja,
mal gucken, vielleicht auch nicht,
aber seitdem ich jetzt quasi sechs Tage
die Woche was mache, aber das meiste davon
so easy, dass es eben nicht
weh tut den Tag
danach in den Beinen, ist
das insgesamt linear
immer alle paar Monate ein paar Prozent
besser geworden, und jetzt
ist bei mir so, also ich hab mal angefangen,
mit, äh, nicht cycling, cycling
mach ich, ist, äh, noch nicht
seit Anfang an, ähm, ich hab angefangen
hier, sagt auch mein, äh,
wie sieht man's denn hier,
sieht man gar nicht, ja,
ähm, also ich hab mal angefangen,
meine ersten paar Runden waren, äh,
acht Minuten, weiß ich nicht,
acht Minuten vierzig oder so pro Kilometer,
und da war ich, da war, da fand ich
schon echt anstrengend, fünf Kilometer zu rennen
mit acht Minuten vierzig,
da hatte ich den Eindruck, ey, gleich, gleich
fällt dir das Bein ab,
und mittlerweile
ist mein,
meine normale,
ich renn mal eine Runde
ohne großartig Anstrengung, ist das so
bei sechsundvierzig pro, pro Kilometer,
also ist schon deutlich besser geworden,
wenn ich jetzt überlege, ich hätt noch zwanzig Kilo weniger,
wird's wahrscheinlich noch deutlich besser gehen,
egal, ich will
jetzt da nicht so lang drauf rumreiten, das
Wichtigste ist tatsächlich, dass man einfach
konstant was macht,
und
zu der einen Frage, die wir noch hatten,
ja, ich wohne ja schon in der City, aber ich
komme relativ schnell raus,
wie ihr das misst, also, ich kann
ja, ich kann ja ungefähr erklären, wie
die, wie die Garmin Uhr das misst,
direkt messen
können die das nicht,
weil dazu müsstest du
quasi dir eine Maske aufziehen,
und ab und zu Blut abnehmen,
so ins Ohr stechen und sowas,
dass du sowas richtig
messen kannst, ja, Sauerstoffaufnahme
und Laktatbildung im Blut,
was es nicht nur alles gibt, kannst du nicht direkt
mit einer Fitnessuhr messen, aber,
was die haben ist,
die haben einen riesen
Datenbestand, und was Garmin
macht ist,
Garmin macht mit ausgewählten Leuten
echte
Tests,
und anhand ihres großen
Datenbestands, was sie haben, plus
den Daten, die sie quasi messen
können, sowas wie
Pulsfrequenz,
die können auch gucken, ein bisschen,
die haben ja, bei der Uhr ist das
so, ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert, so ein Licht dabei,
die können also quasi auch ungefähr gucken,
wie breit sind deine,
deine Adern,
wie viel Sauerstoff geht, also so ganz
komische Dinge, also sie können quasi anhand
der Daten, die sie messen können,
und anhand der echten Vergleichsmessung,
die sie mit echten Personen gemacht haben,
und aufgrund ihres riesen
Datenbestands, so Pi mal Daumen,
relativ genau
sagen, was deine Werte sind,
auch von Werten, die sie nicht direkt
messen können. Und es gab,
genug Tests, kann man sich auch auf YouTube
angucken, die haben quasi dann echte
Tests gemacht, in irgendeinem,
bei irgendeinem Sportmediziner,
und sind zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass
das, was Garmin misst, mit den
Uhren, beziehungsweise das, was Garmin
anzeigt, relativ
nah an dem ist, was die auch bei dem
echten Test gemessen haben. Deswegen würde ich sagen, hey,
das ist nicht hundertprozentig akkurat,
das ist bestimmt plus, minus ein bisschen,
aber es ist nicht weit weg
von der Realität. Ey, was ich
mache, hat noch irgendjemand gefragt, ich
gehe
zum größten Teil
Rennen, aber auch ab und zu
Fahrradfahren.
Ich würde sagen,
ich würde sagen, so
70-30, so 70%
Rennen, 30% Fahrradfahren.
Muss auch immer das Wetter dazu passen, zum Fahrradfahren.
Ich mag Fahrradfahren nicht, wenn scheiß Wetter ist.
Ich habe hier so einen Smart Trainer,
aber den benutze ich eigentlich nur, wenn es kalt ist.
Ja, gibt's auch.
Ja, genau, siehste, das ist gar nicht
schlecht, was die Dinger anzeigen.
Können wir jetzt, stimmt, stimmt, ja.
Äh, der
Run sagt 43, 43.
Das, mein Run
VO2 Max ist tatsächlich dann 2 weniger.
Da bin, da bin ich nur
Durchschnitt. Ich müsste halt echt
einfach noch 10 Kilo weniger wiegen.
Aber, es geht halt
nicht von heute auf morgen, zumal
ich auch, seitdem ich mich mehr bewege,
ich fresse so viel,
alter, Leute. Hätte ich das früher
fressen, wäre ich, wäre ich, hätte ich
jetzt 150 Kilo gehabt oder so.
Seitdem ich mich mehr
bewege, habe ich so viel Hunger.
Und ich fresse so viel Zeug,
aber ich nehme insgesamt trotzdem ab.
Meine Ernährung ist
schlecht, da könnte man enorm viel rausholen,
aber da bin ich zu faul für.
Also, ich futtere ein bisschen gesünderes
Zeug als früher.
Bis vielleicht ein bisschen weniger und
bisschen, bisschen gesünderes Zeug, also ist
noch was Grünes dabei und so.
Ich bin weit, wirklich sehr weit davon
entfernt, irgendeinen Ernährungs,
irgendeinen Plan zu haben, was Ernährung angeht.
Heute gibt's
Spaghetti Bolognese. Das ist, glaube ich, noch
ganz okay.
Was sagst du? Service wie HelloFresh? Keine Ahnung, hab ich nie ausprobiert.
Ja, so, jetzt gucken wir,
was Engine X macht.
Wenn ich das Fenster finde.
Oh, mal das hier, ha? Ja, Engine X.
Alles klar.
Kein Nudel mit Lachs, Nudel mit Tomatensauce gibt's heute.
Okay, wo sind wir
stehen geblieben? Ah, genau, jetzt kam das ganze
Faber-Zeug so langsam, aber sicher auf.
Das fassen
hier wahrscheinlich... Mir leuchtet's
echt nicht ein, dass Leute freiwillig Sachen unter
IIS laufen lassen. Und 2005 ist mir's
auch schon nicht eingeleuchtet.
Es gibt für mich eigentlich, ehrlich gesagt, zwei
Sachen. Ja, es gibt für mich
Engine X als Webserver. Das ist, wenn ich
statischen Content ausliefern will
oder was brauche als Reverse-Proxy
für Zertifikate, dann Engine X.
Und ansonsten den eingebauten Webserver
meines Application Frameworks.
Ja, also das heißt, kestrelby.net
oder...
Ich weiß nicht, wie der Go-Web-Server heißt oder
Node.js oder was auch immer.
Warum ist der IIS gerade so einen fetten Sprung
gemacht? Oh, Microsoft Shit!
Nein! Stopp!
Mach, dass es aufhört!
Ah, okay.
Okay, Google Cloud.
2007?
So lange?
Da hat doch gerade mal
AWS erst angefangen und Google war
später, oder?
Sind die so früh schon gewesen?
Also ich habe in meiner Ausbildung nichts von
Google Cloud damals mitgekriegt.
Aber jetzt sind wir so in halbwegs
modernen Zeiten. Hier, Engine X am Start.
Ja. Engine X, beste.
Engine X hat ein bisschen
gebraucht, bis es abgehoben ist. Da kann ich mich
noch dran erinnern. Die Leute haben damals gesagt,
ey, warum soll ich Engine X benutzen, wenn ich
Apache benutzen kann? Ja.
Vergleich mal die Config zwischen Apache
und Engine X, Alter. Die Apache Config versteht
kein Mensch.
Engine X verstehen vielleicht zwei Menschen.
Jawoll!
Echt? IES, weg.
Weg damit.
Was macht da jetzt der Engine X Fork vom
alten Maintainer?
Der ist so bekannt, dass ich bis jetzt nicht mal wusste,
dass es einen Engine X Fork gab.
Warum baut das Google Zeug
so krass?
IES, weg damit.
IES, einfach verschwinden, please.
Ah.
Lightspeed? Auch noch nicht gehört.
Ist auch gleich wieder weg? Oder ist er wieder?
Die battlen sich aber richtig gerade.
Ich bin der Nächste in IES.
Node? Ja. Das muss ja früher
oder später mal kommen.
Und Chat? Ich war natürlich richtig blöd
am Anfang.
Ich hab jetzt nur an die Sachen gedacht, die man sich selbst
installieren kann. Aber klar, was ist mit den
ganzen Cloud-Anbietern und den Sachen?
Da hab ich überhaupt nicht dran gedacht, vorhin.
Es ist kein Wunder, dass Cloud-Flair und Google
und Zeug
da jetzt zunehmen wird.
Bin ich, dass der einen Fork gestartet hat?
IES, kannst du nicht einfach
verschwinden? Guck mal.
Node.js. Node.js.
So langsam, aber sicher. Das wird noch ein bisschen
mehr werden, Clay.
Wo ist das ganze Java-Backend-Zeug?
Da hätte ich eigentlich gedacht, dass wir da jetzt
irgendwas in der Richtung sehen werden.
Vielleicht doch .NET, aber...
OpenResty.
OpenResty ist Nginx.
Weiß nicht, warum das extra
ein extra Dings kriegt. Das ist...
Ja, also wo das ganze Java-Zeug ist, wundert
mich eigentlich. Ich dachte, das wäre ein bisschen weiter oben mit dabei.
Hat er noch. Hat er noch ein paar Jahre.
Ach, wir haben ja Others.
Ja, okay. Aber jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Wenn andere 20%
haben,
müsste man das nicht mal irgendwie aufschlüsseln?
Weil da ist alles drin.
Da ist das ganze Java-Zeug drin.
Da ist Ruby drin. Da ist Go
drin. Da ist .NET drin.
Das wäre tatsächlich mal ganz interessant.
Vor dem Java-Stuff hängt auch ein normaler
Webserver. Nö, muss nicht. Muss nicht.
Nö.
Da hängt oftmals ein Reverse-Proxy
davor, dass ich im Zertifikats-Gram und
FSL-Terminierung und sowas kümmere.
Aber du brauchst
heutzutage nicht mehr wie zu PHP-Zeiten
einen Webserver, um deine Anwendung laufen zu lassen.
Es ist...
Egal, wo du hinguckst, ist eigentlich einer dabei.
Egal, ob Go, Ruby,
Spring Boot mittlerweile bei...
Ist das eigentlich noch Tomcat bei Spring Boot?
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Java.
Kestrel bei .NET.
Der Node.js-Server und so.
Du brauchst heute eigentlich keinen Webserver mehr davor.
PHP hat aber nur,
glaube ich, einen Development-Mode-Server.
Die sagen auch, live sollst du das nicht benutzen.
Glaube ich zumindest. Bin ich ganz sicher.
Ähm, also...
Das... Others aufgeschlüsselt
fände ich tatsächlich mal ganz interessant.
Ja, und Cloudflare ist es im Prinzip
auch nur wegen ihrem
DDoS-Protection-Service.
Im Endeffekt hängt dann Cloudflare
vor einem Nginx Reverse-Proxy vor einer
Node-Anwendung oder sowas.
Das ist Lightspeed. Ich habe davon noch nie gehört.
Also jetzt mal ganz ehrlich.
Wenn Others 25%
haben,
das könnte man doch schon nochmal aufschlüsseln.
Ja, HA-Proxy und alles
Mögliche noch dabei. Cuddy und
Traffic und
was es noch so alles gibt.
Wobei, kann Traffic eigentlich statischen Content surfen?
Es ist Others sogar auf Platz 1.
Also die Statistik ist für den Arsch.
Seriously. Komplett
für den Arsch.
Das ist eigentlich mit Abstand das Interessanteste jetzt.
Das ist
massive sinnlos.
Aber was ich interessant finde,
Node.js konstant immer wieder
kleine Prozente dabei.
Ist noch nie gefallen.
Ja, Microsoft hat in ihrer Cloud doch kein
IIS laufen. Die sind doch nicht bescheuert.
Also, das ist
wirklich sinnlos.
Ja, für
irgendwelche
Only-Applikationen, die sie da anbieten.
Also, das weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht für Sharepoint oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber ich weiß auch, ehrlich gesagt,
ich kenne auch nicht die Architektur beispielsweise
von Microsoft 365.
Das einzige, was ich von Microsoft 365
weiß, ist, dass es ein
React-JS-Frontend ist.
Wie die das Backend-mäßig machen,
habe ich keine Ahnung. Aber die war
ja
nicht so dolle gewesen.
Jaja, das ist klar.
Das ist nicht nur Nginx hinter Cloudflare.
Das sind Cloudflare-Proxys auf Nginx
auf die eigentliche Anwendung.
Das ist jemand, der keinen Plan hat von dem, was er postet.
Ja, das war jetzt...
Mich hätte es eher interessiert, wie...
Es wäre cool, hätten die nochmal
eine extra Statistik gehabt, nur für die Others.
Weil da würde mich echt interessieren,
wie sich so die Anwendungen verteilen.
Und da ist sicherlich das Java-Zeug
relativ hoch,
.NET relativ hoch und
ja, die ganzen anderen Dinger, die man noch so
gehört hat, hier von Kadi bis Traffic
und alles müsste da auch dabei sein.
Der überwiegende Teil der Nginx-
Installation ist definitiv einfach
ein stinknormaler Reverse-Proxy, der
Zertifikats-Handling macht und SSL-Endpunkt bildet.
Der wird nicht wirklich
die Anwendung serven.
Außer es ist PHP, von dem es
mehr gibt, als man denkt.
Weiß nicht, wie das ist. Benutzen PHP-
Leute heutzutage hauptsächlich Apache
oder Nginx?
Und gibt es auch eine Alternative
eigentlich, PHP-
Anwendungen laufen zu lassen, so nach dem Motto
ich starte PHP.
Der bringt einen eigenen Webserver mit, der auch
als Production-Ready
vom Hersteller vermarktet wird,
oder gesehen wird und dann
Nginx davor.
Ich fand das damals schon immer weird,
wenn man PHP gebastelt hatte, dass man das dann
per CGI oder so
in irgendeinen Webserver rein...
Ganz komisches Zeug.
Ja, ich kenne nur den
Webserver, der in PHP eingebaut
ist. Der wird
aber nur zum Development...
War das nicht Web...
Webbrick?
Ist Ruby, ist der eingebaute
Ruby-Webserver gewesen? Ja, ja, ja.
Webbrick.
Das ist der eingebaute
Ruby.
Webserver.
Den auch keiner verwendet
für Ruby-Anwendungen.
Biden unleashed.
Hat nen Sub gekriegt. Aha.
Massive. Anonymous Gifter.
Pog-Subscription.
Äh.
Leute, mein Sound ist weg.
Der geht noch?
Der macht keinen Sound mehr. Windows.
Warum sagt der nicht nice?
Moment, der Sound geht noch?
Windows, alter!
Per CGI Webserver. Hör mal bloß auf.
So. Leute.
Es ist Zeit.
Nudel mit Tomatensoße.
Ich geh jetzt was futtern. Bis später.
Hoffe ich.
Macht's gut. Bis denn.
Cu.